you're a grass I always feel now sure
laughter yeah yeah welcome back the true
jolly podcast Christmas dear
I'd rather get caught watching porn than
watch an air samaan so you have a
favorite girl doesn't watch Devdas a I
bought my sueded a car I'll be straight
with you Brian I'm [__] waiting for
that video all right so all right I know
people who have been counseled
previously which is why I aim is I said
to will and so I offered on a bit of
paper and you know you come to the end
but you want to finish the video and
I've got good tits and a perfect chunky
ass but she's got a boyfriend you don't
know the message means sense Brian
either but it's absolute finalists I
think it's been [__] ages since I had
a woman on the pod yo what will say
favorite sexual position I've got the
iPod Pro why would they call the
good Merry Christmas here coach we're
ready we're ready and we are rolling
welcome back the true jolly podcast
Christmas day with my extended family
this is no tradition it's a Christmas
tradition everyone everyone who's lonely
can sit with us that's lovely isn't it
yeah
what's your favorite Christmas song just
be a mystery that's actually a banger
though no I'm not is it good we can't
play it
copyright just call Robbie and play of
sunrise it's about a woman at that
office party called bad Sharon who you
you shunt there you sugar can I sing it
will rap bad Sharon from the our fears
make the champagne that scared of face
right Tyson Fury call Santa a big
daughter
I'm the naughty just a question loves
this year what's the best mobile game
you've played because in this video is
sponsored by Rage legends again everyone
grab your phones out we've got a nice
Christmas present for you all it's
really good I know you've already heard
about raid everywhere but there's a
great reason for it raid is one of the
top ranked RPG games on the Google Play
Store and it's been nominated as a
finalist for Google play's best 2019
user Choice Awards could I just say
about this is our force prime deal with
red shadow legends I just want to thank
you for giving your money to us and not
these gentlemen yeah although round the
table the link will
in the description below for read I mean
Brian I hear you ask this Graham's crazy
popular isn't it almost 15 million
downloads in the last six months that's
what was that you also say Brian so what
is rate good what is RIT's mech dark
fantasy done right yeah my memory would
be better by now Steven I apologize you
would think I'm getting Alzheimer's well
it's probably also because you've been
busy discovering 13 spectacular
locations enjoying a full fully void
story campaign and raid with friends so
for Christmas if you want a free game
nerd oh Lord and now with Christmas
coming to raid you can check out these
super cool Christmas vibey champions and
they're already in the game there's a
new fusion event for Christmas as well
it's only available for next couple of
weeks because obviously it's Christmas
you can basically combine a few
champions and get a new Christmas
looking champion I'm hoping getting his
name is Tom in the cold and the best
part is is free to play insert the
screenshot here you can find me under
the newscaster so go to the special
links in the description and any new
player will get 100 thousand silver one
energy refill one day XP boost and one
free champion boom this is about us
champion all the treasure is what if you
right here hurry up this is only
relevant for 30 days so get out this
amazing so what are you waiting for
the links in the description we've been
asking people on toilet what should we
talk about yeah it's being up being a
bit up had reading some of those replies
thanks to everyone who replied not
actually apparently people want us to
talk about the YouTube awards what our
YouTube awards are awards other words we
can give each other the awards if we
want yeah we've got some topics like
breakout star funniest Global War worst
YouTube o most improvement Beauty gaming
best youtuber let's do one at a time
bloody hell I'm just letting them know
what's coming alright setting it up nice
long-form content will I guess you've
got a lot of time to play around with on
podcast Phillip breakout YouTube star he
doesn't a 19 what we've seen Zach and
yeah
only second I mean you know there any
second to rate that lads
and I don't I don't especially who did
the the dressed up like a supermodel
awesome it yeah that was good
you want a massive check out for my new
CBD line coming 2029 you know I'm
getting into the CBD business about time
wow I've always wanted to sell cannabis
and now I can finally do it yeah legally
yeah in the UK I got the CD like what
does CD Central cognitive discs yes good
are we just in suck and Jaipur is there
Nikko's of the content he does now it's
really hone that down this year yeah one
other on one of the I mean it's a bit
bias sure very pious trees bond
molesters win ratio since he came on
here since they got him on the kick off
I write me some sort of good omen this
is that he's then you're like sort of
mascot he it was so weird how we sort of
found him randomly and then all the
city's giving Jimmy forty the player
yeah I think she's not that Jamie Vardy
look-alike given in the award oh god
yeah he tweets me a lot yeah a good way
all a man that looks like somebody else
that is the main reason should not be
very point of verification is to
Stockman who looks like the Jamie Vardy
look-alike who's trying to take his ID
he'd be now sitting going could you drop
my art in you pricks like that people
the [__] on it's a Jamie Vardy seven I'm
pretty sure that's what
okay sitting there on Christmas table so
is it is it duck and Jerry I would vote
that's I like that but sure good guy
they said quality if the stuff I feel
like I'm over the loop here because I've
seen enough of this stuff by I seen one
of their bounce around I've seen you've
rated them for it I break them before
yeah all right next one other white guys
next one was P I mean this youtuber
looking at me thinking sure you could
take the award home with your eyes
closed but which one of you wants it
it's not me a rogue show I'd say give it
those he's the funniest but like not I
know just because of his general
demeanor
yeah there's something really funny
about it and what do you think about him
and fighters Jake yeah fine Jake because
I don't say that it's happening what
other Jake was it gonna be what well
just I don't know I think it's a really
hard faith football for them I think
they're Baker's of his status in regard
so like how many subs he's got on him
being like a FIFA youtuber yeah if he
beats the [__] out of Jake it would be
like the Rocky of oh my god it's a most
ridiculous timeline I've seen in ages
it's so funny
like I remember I first met him on the
first Wembley [__] website next we're
just getting to know people nobody was
really comfortable around me at that
table and he just start talking to me
and he was like yeah I've never played
professional like in a stadium before I
actually couldn't even get a game for my
son daily to him and he was like a bit
overweight not very confident and then
all of a sudden he's like shredded few
years later and he's fighting Jake like
it is a mental glorg he's also pressed
him so much so Jake was like now I'm not
fighting that no no I find that guy he's
been so relentless
tryna get into this gate was a [__] I
[__] I can't live the really really [__]
he's our guys you can sew on any video
without seeing
I think Jake's the better like technical
box are the two but like the engine of
gibble is gonna force a real fight it
was such a good fight as well with TGIF
it was such a good fight Josh I'm a bit
yeah
out of all the YouTube boxes I think Jay
is the one who sort of done a little bit
harsh because he performed amazingly
yeah yeah and he doesn't really get like
recognized for how good it was so many
different thing mental he's good at
cementing his head into a microwave
these he does that he's doing up his own
house he's made music he's made everyone
seems love his murder its clothing yeah
he's really good at DIY yeah rock you
all should do like changing rooms or
something for YouTube well Bradshaw yeah
sure alright so what we say funniest
YouTube Cuba
I don't think it's been the best year
one of the Americans like code econom
with it oh yeah cuz like kind of
accidentally being funny yeah I would
say DBMS in that category as well like
unknowingly blue van being you see
recently the whole intros like this is
gonna hit you in the face
yes you gonna win all the face awards oh
good you're getting a beauty blocker as
well so all we like vote for Americans
or not whoever the [__] we want no
babies no babies but jason nash in his
videos with us that's the problem
first now she's funny is not youtube I'd
say no Miller yeah no I don't know who
no one ever is Steven Troy's oh that guy
Steven took that one you I've never seen
you Hama Steven like that name just put
his head down I really be the funny one
he's Cody coach true Geordie yeah
brilliant
I believe on man would be by my in terms
of who's made me laugh the most he's
made me laugh more although who's the
guy that he goes to on key Steve I mean
visually impaired yeah and he's
literally visually and he's got a blind
uncle who I think he calls him uncle
Steve I don't know we're testing a new
lube today we got glow-up award who's
who's become like handsome of Norway I
mean I'm not I'm not I mean I faint
George me me let's get set he's looking
great and how des does look good it will
we'll never know that oh yeah thankfully
you know who wants who would be
listening and wanting this it's Jim Jim
pictures Instagram oh yeah oh yeah and
then and ever and we went circles
probably me Millicent yeah all right
it's I think bazinga Stephanie you've
got to give into it in terms of a glow
up yeah yeah when you see younger
pictures of him I must his [__]
mental whole changed I think it's mean
mo to just people who are chubby in
general no but they're not good-looking
people that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying he's lost weight and he looks
great
it proves I was hunting the whole time
he she couldn't say it I find up in
terms of the channel was [__] because in
that case Josh Peters yeah yeah take off
Zana so he's really got me that he's
actually and then I thought Google did
he owns the [__] company who
sponsored me technically we'll doesn't
really get me a prodigy
the only way you've got me a brand that
was actually owning the company who
sponsored me yeah same time next time
your brandy oh yes I'm not
at the same time it also shows what a
difficult task is right now Michelle
I've heard bad things about them because
yeah they're just sort of leaking you're
in forward I made that's all I want guy
also I also heard the people at the top
Iraq touching kids they are me
everywhere you know Kirkham on the gore
we keep touching kids yeah
come cook them he's got like really
handsome this year he has always been
and now he's eating properly para
shoulders getting older he's maturing
into a man ignoring I mean top three is
just because you know your chiseled this
I can't believe it made true yeah is
right your fifty J thing I got four days
in a house gonna look ten days into a
days it was good you know how you got me
on it and a half is that all Judy
because you're still making videos and
[__]
I gave up Doody who's training you then
nah he does it with me alright it
doesn't work me he was a PT many moons
ago yeah okay he's doing it was doing
shrugs the other day and pulled a muscle
on his neck he was the first person I
saw after jj1
yeah and I just run over and grabbed him
and he looked at me like because I saw
you next day I looked at my cameras like
I was did you get in the after pie yeah
I didn't you to Jemison know so we
turned up was one Oaks or something yeah
dude he had lost his card and the calyx
was there as well he's gone straight in
and the woman's turned to me and she's
gone the s $15 and I was like I've
any cash so I was like cow cow cow about
50 was like I've got anything walked in
and then the woman I went to play on
he's just what he hasn't given you 15
dollars so the one when he's on the list
so I went so am i - whose list though I
didn't even say JJ so it ksi she went no
you're not not give it and Konya he
wanted too much and therefore he can't
have it control about know you've seen
him make it was either a sacrifice to
making videos so I think that gives it
even more worst youtuber no way are we
all just confirming that was me yeah not
that he's bothered about it it was Chuck
yeah why she is there Oh who's the worst
I never thought of like youtubers who
were good and have declined massive back
to back categories that they're all
competing general is right I genuinely
think there's been like quite a bad year
for us like it's not very but like
YouTube generally like I see like 92018
it felt like it was everyone was on fire
everyone and now we're 20 night now like
button right how many great YouTube
videos watch it like you know what I
mean I don't feel like it's been like I
think you've had a great year you're the
start your year was woeful terrible
funny wasn't it splendid I was buzzing
for you and I saw why you attendant
it was like it was a good year and I'm
aleris but you have smashed it since
then it's funny how being embarrass can
sometimes so spare you it's great now
people have such like a low opinion
every around this table you can do no
wrong when everyone knows that you're a
a BDSM freak it's great it's great shame
surely you've had a great year you know
what you're not really what you do that
it means me smashed it and the door was
[__] great I was good it was just
like taking a month off that I didn't
expect to be as good as it was it was
hard for me I mean we all know that cuz
I had nothing you told me nothing so I'm
like what the [__] are these to throw
out this week my windows like production
mic and everything was going on take all
the claims for the production yeah you
probably could have done it with less
production but the point is I walked
away going they've done themselves proud
there what was the what was the one
night where you were like it's like the
most product like the very first one
because I've never been like a
theatrical type like at school Nativity
or like cleaner number three I was never
and then loads astray what are you
nervous oh my god yes like terrible I
was more worried about you than him
naturally because he's got more
experience and it is just natural born
in UConn's
yeah when I'd seen you you've probably
done like I don't know tame a fire then
oh yeah you were like clockwork like I
could tell this was like a smooth
operation I think it's when you know
when you're going out that you've got
something really good to deliver and Max
Smith
like when we did bounce between the two
is like we got five minutes on and then
Steven would take over it was kind of
just flowed really well like the people
that did it with what helped us a lot
you can always Max as well how much was
like improv and then how much was all my
every word scripted although one night
in Manchester we'd spent at least like
20 to 30 minutes with max rehearsing
combats to her to heckles yeah she was
our biggest crowd we thought gotta be on
it for tonight so he had he had some
really funny ones and we just kept going
over it and then he gets out there and
some kid shouts Greg's cuz that was one
of the types by emphasizing every Greg's
in Manchester he just goes said no
swearing in this your lives like a young
you'll play it safe just go yeah did you
enjoy touring yeah I did even even when
it was like a really long car journey
from Ipswich to Cardiff hmm yeah some
big assassinations in the UK thank God
thanks to the Ipswich craft for turning
on for the last five minutes of the show
really good stuff why they dead well
they hope is the worst really surprises
so our crowd quite like to shout nonce
I know Belfast liked it a lot more than
the rest I suppose you get like one or
two a half and then a bit yeah did you
get that a lot Belfast Warriors why gets
it there's someone in the crowd that
doesn't know like YouTube culture in
that and then like people just shout
announcer yes YouTube culture and
someone maybe losing lots of money for
them not knowing what YouTube cost was
about that would be crazy wouldn't it
imagine if say you know loads people
calling you a nonce lost you lots of
money deals this year both have fallen
through but I got paid for both so it
was a real winner was that tick-tock
this year this tick tock tick tock in
their MLB whistle sports who believe
they have to have a hand in that channel
so have you ever been heckled in the
street by any fans fans I suppose they
just yeah this one go show me there what
time is it and then I looked at my phone
II took it are we on worse youtuber yeah
I think yeah the point is is like
someone who you have to a certain style
who you really within the group of
people that is drop I'm not gonna lie
Annoying Orange his channels not weight
used to be yeah I'm not a big fan of all
the this year all of the corporate
channels that have started up so sort of
skive started putting all the stuff up
on their Channel and BT not YouTube
YouTube channels oh they could all been
collectively a bad award every time we
can take my time with this and actually
get a good I reckon the worst you should
cherish year was happy hour after always
left I can imagine the watch names gone
down because he likes to [__] a waffle
like I just want to thank Jack for
getting us on the podcast and never
uploading it it was great brilliant so
the joke's on me yeah no you can be
bothered he said yes weird you said only
do the big boys like this I tell you I
don't remember okay yeah it's Christmas
coming up them sweet see that's 20
billeted he said to you you want to be
breastfed again is anyone in this group
ever tasted breast milk
no because for me I've had so much
commutes about me this is not a big deal
now so I was one [__] a girl who's
actually like not long had a kid I just
saw at it without thinking yeah how long
I want to see you like that
straining finally it compare I'm gonna
say like eighteen months two years old
that the kid was
so they're in the other room or what
about babysat away oh yeah sure funny
remember I was like 20 at the time yeah
sure and yeah boom and you know it'll
surprise me
tasty good taste good oh yes like what
is she raven Del Mar okay well she
thought I'd deliberately done it I was
like yeah oh yeah will you look out like
mama so then yeah you know do you know
where me myself in - yeah
wasn't like that yeah so I'm sucking up
in the middle and then it just splashes
out and I'm like psycho warm sugary milk
way as if you'd put it in the microwave
normal like full fat milk can pop the
couple of sugars in it straight no no
like full fat from a cow she wasn't
missing your milk right so my wife's you
sure this year is true Jordan yeah there
you go
I genuinely don't think he's been such a
good year or such a bad Yoshi has been
such a level year I mean can we talk
about taxes
okay sorry early Andy any milk that not
like you yeah he just sort of lost it in
her face with it yeah tank News was a
good day chunk news I thought was the
funniest thing ever
yeah it was such a like I've never been
ripped off so quite yeah it was great
yes I don't actually mind that good on
it now musk is not a threat to you you
know I I think he deserves it just
because these changes known from
comedyshortsgamer and that in itself
yeah does anyone else think of comedy
shorts if he's wearing comedy shorts so
have we got a worse future well no crown
crown that Jim Dave's on more sorry for
dead you by the way no no I don't know
what's going on with him I hope he's
having a lovely Christmas dear ya know
this year
I am happy that they've like seemed like
sort of I think that's because JJ's did
it cuz he's just messaged him online and
not yeah okay actually third she
probably yeah of course online that was
a bad move wasn't it yeah what great
going on impulse it was funny it was a
bit funny that I want it it was so
bizarre
like the whole period now just feels
really weird almost like a fake
storyline or something it feels
threatened it feels written suppose
we'll never know coming up the pink one
though who who wants alcohol who wants a
change in me what do we want to be off
dollard's
I'm absolutely Paul gasps go about him
kissing a woman on the train I think he
got away on the basis they didn't have
quite enough to sort of nail him because
the story when I read it was like I
often kiss people who feel inferior
because they are labeled far I've been
labeled far too it's like what kind of
mental [__] is not when you read it
as well from what the lawyer actually
said in court
you're like the lawyer literally
defended him saying remember his goal at
ninety six in the jury's head you're
like are you joking to be fed the worst
of it was when rail moat came in with
the fishing remember the time oh good
old Morty has some people Newman has not
been enough big serial killers yeah he
was definitely the best one if it was a
reward for that for the deck you know
give it road when Gaza turned up with
the cons and the chicken and yeah not
pure pan so he's behind you Craig rebel
ball addresses a day drink what you want
no no no I will be saying I'd say what
is dumb
cookies revolution who did his vote
fallen so you made all labor Diana that
was that was like the biggest proof that
Twitter is [__] in history there's
like this is not a [__]
representation of real life people on I
wonder how many people actually suddenly
voted labour say yeah she's like a gym
influencer grace Beverley she's got a
great fit or something coming over she
lost a load it you're like you see her
she lost her yeah she is she sorry grace
if you watching unhealthily big just she
was one of the first ones that I just
took them Chris bees straight away yeah
but she's a big bottom tactical voted
pro-labor and stuff yeah and she lost a
lot of followers based on it yes I'm
saying no he's tell you your favorite
influences were so loud during Black
Friday for not saying anything now yeah
which is a good point sorry so she Toria
she knows yeah UN Lib Dems Dan you Alex
yeah yeah that I was hoping BNP will be
on there oh my god have a last thanks
for that Stephen yeah well way we could
get our followers by the police over
here yuzu coffee on say it's not she
said now I'm go
I always feel national yeah yeah
and all the women who put up with
youtubers everywhere of this industry
talk about that yes on the side he's not
in the apartment you don't count
it's slander I just put it in there not
I didn't turn it on so where's the real
crime the real crime is that and put it
in the [__] dishwasher the other way
up that's almost like well I saw a
between TV like algae not known it's AI
well maybe I wasn't raised properly so
it does in every situation it wouldn't
be your fault one of my one of the
videos I laughed at the most this year
was a video that Alex made right really
who the [__] you were going in on slow
[Applause]
dishwasher that you [__] up
it's a lovely slaw sir can we just see
it I never said that I was genuinely
sorry give me a cop
that's very good no it was em it was
[__] them the guy did the McDonald's
video money Oh white by name - what
really big screen offers when you're so
dead pardon you're like youtubers don't
do adverts like this anymore we're all
depressed now it's so true he was like
this every youtuber off camera is so -
it was so so Jimmy's is you so happy to
be in a McDonald's yeah it's like we
know you don't we both did really funny
videos are all three of us before vistas
was the best of when I watched that I
was like I was thinking chat scared here
it's so much better when he sees this
funny cuz I watch both videos and I
thought we'll smash those guys so it was
really good it was fun class well that
was such a weird moment when he did that
the thing that one of the things I
missed in the video all the comments
picked out is it people who McDonald's I
don't like Donald that was that was so
weird that was one of the weirdest
moments yeah yeah because he hadn't done
anything that wrong like in terms of
didn't hurt anyone's for surveys is when
you're only white you've got to be
careful but it was it was Tory and then
you do that it's a real problem it was
one of the most misjudged videos oh if I
really wanted to make a video that Jack
- a really great video okay it's like
he's saving you guys yeah he was like
Jack hasn't made a good one
I was literally sat there struggling
like not uploaded in a month and I saw
that I was like I'm going to plate yeah
oh yeah yeah
like a McDonald's a t-shirt it's funny
because I still think you went back to
McDonald's again loads of engagements
are talking about this could I get a
free appetizer
what about we got Most Improved youtuber
not like not like breakout star but like
once we already knew about but like I've
really up the level I'd say Stevens
uploaded loads this yeah well you've
gotta stop thank you that I will say
actually there was a good video that I
watched all the way through I don't
really watch a lot of people's videos or
through your video in Hawaii was good
well yeah the race from one side of the
island to the other was like I watched
it it was a bit I almost jealous that
you've done that video is that good yeah
it was really good like genuinely my
favor favorite reaction this year was
when when Lawrence found out you were in
Hawaii because he loves traveling right
yeah and I was the one who went oh wills
in Hawaii yeah and like his but not in
there like like Jackie was like we're
stuck yeah making the [__] pickle and
they're in Hawaii
where did something wrong yeah what a
Lonnie joke yeah what I love me moment
that was that was hello it was great it
was great
I used to slug you off to my family
about the lack of Fe your food the
change that round
it wasn't even most the second channel I
think I've been really funny on there so
I think you should really give a world
credit for Mike the way those other
people for that second channel is really
amazing for five minutes he's thinking
finally and then next thing you know ZZ
video ask him to come play fifa for an
hour first now I don't he'll actually
what you actually not paying me on the
second channel on the podcast he was
getting thousands right yeah
he's getting paid an exposure on his
lovely all for the exposure
yes yeah yeah Most Improved definitely
improved a lot I guess
Niko's had a really good day but I don't
know his latest video attitude have any
of you seen Niko's is latest videos
incredible yeah yeah making really good
videos - making really good YouTube
videos yes what would just go like
poppers - yeah I'd give it to him he was
already sick so it's like yeah yeah he's
leveled up but not now I wouldn't say
like the most improved in terms of like
I came in from the [__] is you want
someone who'd gone from me I guess above
average to like smashing Josh Peters is
done yes I think I think you have to you
it's a Josh because he really went from
making like videos that were good but
would never do well on YouTube but
really I'd crack him down I'll make a
video with job really well on you yeah I
think Josh's are showers and yeah yeah
he's actually like okay when I first met
him I thought like I kind of shouldn't
like you by still dude I like it you
know what I mean he's a good lad
yeah he's totally different than me but
he's a solo just when he does have
McDonald's Brando and it'll go stunning
he went from making content that I would
like rip off yes and I wish I was making
yes so I think you go give us Josh yeah
making content beauty youtuber someone
suggested I mean James Charles anyone he
blocked me on Twitter YouTube as I would
shag James Charles now you've seen the
latest picture within the McLaren got
his arse out in a McLaren yes
it's a bit weird cuz I'm not sure how
bad it's for a shot is it not a real
looking McLaren who's that so miss James
as you got a Wickham he's got an even
better bum than I do
no you have a very nice but there's a
lovely
killed you yeah looks a little bit like
a premiere don't know how much you're
trying but it looks a little bit like a
cat whiskers haha James have you watch
them come on the podcast then no windows
outspoken age is ever since well car
ruin that yeah but you were in James
Chargers hotel room or something when
you meet ace no but not like that
no I didn't say that wait wait me Jamie
Jamie spike for a bit met a few times
might after is a big controversy at a
conversation about that as very
interesting conversation you don't
normally meet people lost a million
subscribers so that was I was a softer
you party yeah yeah after that why do
why does it call a party I have no clay
so what's she doing now she's still
making videos she's made a lot of money
at emotes didn't go down well despite
for a bit it was quite a quite an
interesting character because I I lie is
mental I went over there I thought I'd
hold up here anymore
what's his name I'm Alex was in Korea
songs me if there's anything any
youtuber needs to learn from this year
it's what happen between that phase
bunks and his girlfriend like all the
text he sent she's like she's like
tweeting I'll sort no but this is a
relationship this is a relational note
to text this is a relationship though
I'm talking about like when you have a
relationship with another infant and
Nick turns bad she went a [__] town
on him like she I felt sorry for him so
he's like in the same way you must buy
it out in my memories no if they split
up and he was idea let's keep it classy
let's be dignified
stop see always lover and then with
see you can say that but he did cheat so
watch Wow let's keep it closed agree at
that moment right we're gonna keep this
classy edenian and then and then later
she goes ah [__] it
Oh another boss I don't know but to
cheat on someone and then you can't
really then be in the business you're
gonna pay the price
Chili's a fire grease if you really
think about it he probably should've
watched that entire documentary Shane
Dawson didn't gone well maybe this won't
go too well for me because she kind of
did it on like a 20 million view video
so he's gonna laugh I'm on it
I just felt a bit sorry for him because
I know but like she just hammered him
you know me like you just treated like I
love you and she was like did you love
me when oh yeah every everything
underneath of that did you love me when
you shot this girl she does when he did
this no girlfriend lifted well I assume
that sorry I was at their choice
commercial be like Israeli like big time
this year as he like he asked me for a
collab I still a sign up a huge deal
with like beets or saying they just
disappeared off the face they're just a
superb I did a video on YouTube we got
[__] canceled honey they get canceled
oh god I must be weird when you're so in
the limelight for a little while and
then suddenly it just completely goes
you never know when you're at the top
yeah j16 for baby mike is full of pigs
and trough is that must be weird
can I go for away yes you can show jack
just follow Chuck yeah what what's the
next what was that Awards I'll tell you
what I [__] hate the happy hour
podcast I think James cuz the comeback
like Mike was unbelievers composing that
is the video of him singing it's mating
crate
I was just like oh dear Lord but you're
not the target audience and suppose
the one where he's like syrup on the
when people really think they can sing
in their BIOS or confidence but I think
like YouTube is one long
please take part in my lie yeah I mean
we're and basically people are going
it's odd because this is fight MMA guy I
follow call Luke Thomas and he's great
ever me analyst and he like he watched
her fighting he's watched a lot of other
YouTube something he's like I feel like
youtubers like people who aren't that
talented just sort of horsing Lords of
things that Lords people do better but
they're doing a lord of different things
skills yeah there are sort of people who
are talented at loads of different
things but they're not amazing at one
thing and if you're that type of
character which should be honest I am
you know I think it's fine unless those
people would stop being like oh yeah but
I actually can do these things that's
I've some people on Twitter be like yeah
well I can do like I can sing I can play
the guitar I can play the piano and
you're either the replacement like oh
you're so talented you're so talented
you are and I read it and I'm like he's
not but you'll believe that now I feel
full that's because it's also like when
we first made that walk the walk
documentary on XR though loads of
comments to like the best documentary
I've ever seen and I remember thinking
you might receive another documentary so
on YouTube that's why there are loads of
kids going this is the best makeup
palette I've ever bought and like well
Jeffrey Stehr jeffree star must be light
up there yep this is amazing you're
right there five well I say yeah because
I mean I jokingly put that shamed or
someone I like James Charles wanna Shane
Dawson when everybody's are always
brilliant I love this palette and I'm so
excited
I thought I pay fifty quid that I always
[__] [__] and I see him as like after
the James Charles stuff I think he's
like a genuine like actual super villain
is he really good at it
because he is easy - it's been the point
where people have gone oh you shouldn't
actually make as many videos and as you
do because he's like generally scary and
will come after you he was at
Northwestern station the train station
that was the weirdest thing is like here
it is full a Vuitton costume it is just
that we can't race they should I don't
think America I think Americans think of
Wigan as like or something like that
it's like this really edgy trendy City
and it runnings like I am wicked what I
like about the beauty community is it's
different like in terms of like if
YouTube was beef with each other in this
country or whatever like it's not really
a big deal like okay but these are
calling for keeps they try to end each
other's hole yeah cuz they know yeah if
I [__] you over I'm gonna make more
money by millions this is gonna make me
ten million extra if I can end your [__]
is ironic that are the biggest [__]
queens are actually the ones who are
playing for the biggest money even JJ
and Logan like punching each other in
the face the money difference isn't
gonna make that much of a difference
between those two
whereas bloody James Charles and jeffree
star bitching about each other makes
much more suffering I didn't realise
since I spoke to him so all that's best
so much fun how many a lot on the light
did she do on that video she first
dropped was it 40 miss a video was
centered around her brand like the
amount of unpaid attention well I've
never heard of her before this and then
apparently she made like 20 minute
videos that if you can slip like the
Protestant were dissing yeah he didn't
pretty like promote your two different
products at the same time and they saw
and this was my one and that is closer
though after you watch it you realize
that it is all like that but there's
muscle manipulation you know when you
say though that is clever do you mean by
YouTube standards because I also feel
like if you leave yeah well in a way but
then you were just saying earlier loads
of people haven't mastered anything and
I feel like then when you get on YouTube
we're like oh absolutely
nailed it there but don't take it
someone who's not on YouTube they go
over some de crossbow chair that's weird
I think the difference is the beauty
community light especially meeting James
and a few other people through that like
those guys are on it to a level that
like I've never seen before so when
you'll see what well that they still
talking about the video which they just
like they've got like teams two people
follow them around and stuff not like
that I mean in terms of like how
dedicated they are to YouTube or yeah
yeah like a team of six people follow
them around constantly and I every
conversation is like business business
business for like every hour of the day
yeah I thought while I'm at James it's
like he had to he was I I can only meet
you between 1:00 and 2:00 p.m. so I've
got meetings after that and I was like
so the same áwillá knee we're doing STW
video at any point we're flexible right
from FIFA packs James Charles is doing
that is he America is ahead of that
though our mate where they're sort of
like they've got this ready-made line of
things they see their friends doing it
and then they'll be like I'll get a PA
America as I've read on that though
innit it's such a different culture to
hear especially on YouTube that's why
they're all I hate business it makes it
unlike you enjoy at this point where
you've got seven people following you
around would you like a PA by role
what would you would do you think you'd
actually never seen a movie called the
secretary yeah if you haven't it's the
girl who played she was in the Dark
Knight yeah yeah she bends over the desk
and stares if I was I don't know it's
called pastel net face it's on something
that's put your mange you've washed it
it's a matter wanker here kevin has the
the part of youtube that's quite a down
hill the most support I'm not even like
I'm not even just bringing up because
we're in me and loves especially is you
look at the football channels in 2050
and 16 they were popping up all over now
now so many of them
couple 19 core I've been caught click
forming poor making the views you see
some Kairos ones so even you know you
know no one yeah what one Irish one got
caught [__] doing them click farming
fake interviews caught up in fake news
my favorite one is copper 90 because I
got shaved that the other day and I was
I they have like just good like 2
million view videos have five hundred
likes and 10 min yeah and then you look
at football Republic dead as a doornail
you look at a kick to be dead like
massive or and even the football
creators like you know there's some
football critters who've just
disappeared there's what football teams
well hashtags actually done really well
not touch drugs still going I'm a shot
but I wouldn't would you say the rest of
them have have done any sick societies
I've been great it's great for us
because the kickoffs gone from strength
to strength yeah it wins if all those
people have gravitated to one good piece
of content you've just reminded me the
one person who's really come back strong
this year George Brent Kyle fries indeed
good rebel yep oh yeah I want to say
Johnny
yeah I love the video where you like
beat me up for like 10 minutes has
already good luck I really find it funny
as well when English YouTube's do
American ideas so you'd like you know
mr. beast did all this giving away all
this money a lot of it is quite it feels
government they look even away any money
it feels very American like it feels
like like my most hated videos ever was
when who's that guy who does all those
trick videos yeah he's not one person
I'm sure their videos are fantastical
but they did a video with Chelsea yeah
and like every time someone hit the
crossbar they were acting like the
climax it was so annoying
yeah it's triggering video I have to do
it for content no don't prevail it's a
ridiculous say like on four different
platforms said you like a foreign two
billion views right every single who
cares will swing bouncing of something
else and then and then wrong so I don't
care it's just man it's like that's just
it's gonna work now absolutely good on
them money do you know anyone actually
watches it I when I was first when you
got a hangover and you want to see
someone like hit bailing from a mile
away as they pick the ball off the
crossbar I wish once around with the
40-year old mate yes please I just want
to hear them actually shout what they
really think when they do it like I'm
inferior to everyone else it's not this
isn't you know like the bit where you
just don't get it I don't get that kind
of content wait so you I'm gonna hit
something off something else and it gets
millions of views like to me I can
personally enjoy drawing the balls by
not watching someone else I never think
I never I never put something in the bin
and go hope I shouldn't film that like
that's not yeah I get it I kind of but
for me I'm just like if you've watched
one of those creators ones you've seen
it a million I think that's how that's
how you cheapest think they watch that
stuff but when I go home and see like
all my mates you just watch it you cash
it all the late sale of George live at
home as well
sometimes I say palem will the way I do
view stacking dishwashing when you get
the reactions you know told me once that
you played football I did not yeah we
get it so you've made this out said that
you were like that no no no I put on the
ball player no no no my friends play
football if I was never good enough
right it's like Anna batting point was
able is superior than me
I always thought you've made that in it
in rating from like one too many mints
are all Chris Andy where are you where'd
you well based on the last time I played
with them a lot
Ethan shouted at me a lot so I gave
myself a free Ethan shower day but that
knock you down yeah I was a five foot
six girl I was in goal when he caught
you're not reckoning go on as I bracing
for as I am amazing really kept a clean
sheet so it's quite annoying when it
takes out the side same base of people
there's six people a mess I just called
the Olson we had the winner when Lauren
stand up for the first time we were told
you gonna be around everybody always
terrible for that I didn't say that the
other category we got given was caring
like what what are we thinking of gaming
I think ninja [__] really cool podcast
he did with Isis I don't think it's it's
it's where it was
do you know what chipper you know yeah
he came back from the [__] ashes and
he's banged it no taxes will do that to
you people seen he should join fairs or
surveys chip yeah his main charlie was
just like I was dead end with it yeah
out from like pretty much that we also
like when I was like jerk clean
cancelled I was like well at least I can
always be fortnight in four years yeah I
imagine you're [__] brilliant
I don't fly a play once these these two
coats are having a [__] child there
what you see I just talk about a million
subscribers you know every year it gets
more embarrassed I must admit right the
fact that Stephen hasn't hit a million
don't work hard all your [__] that's why
it's a disgrace and if you went on The
Guardian sudoko as much as I do Brian
you don't need to achievement at YouTube
money offer
next year I'll dare promise what comedy
comedy rise
speaking of which music obviously we
saying that is right now on YouTube how
we always feel no commentary well thanks
thanks yeah well Barry is comedy isn't
it's no always I mean to be seen these
videos why is it dead no debates I think
it's just you shoot goes through phases
where what works works and I think 2016
to 2018 Colin tree work but there's only
so many times you can make the same
video over over again and I think
sometimes I personally really struggle
just find this video I'll tell the same
jokes about it I just think you know HR
just think that was a phase and I think
it's done yeah that's why I'm not
uploading he's because I just have
nothing now well do you think it's been
no calendars in so long red Amaro's one
that was really bog-standard Jack um can
we make sure that we keep that in small
Newcastle Brown Ale is under there Brian
oh it's dog mind it but hello I can do a
nails not that [__] hurts me I was
like the bottle out I'm drinking
anything these days I sang us what more
than anything drinking anything
from crack Neal don't give it a chip yes
chip that is still in an ASMR phase
I [__] love that are you on that - Oh
mate I've been on what you know I'd
rather get caught watching porn then
watch an ASMR yeah well yeah so are you
watching it because you you find the
content funny or are you getting a kick
right no no when we go do an s DW video
you know you got like the 12 slots it's
do you have a favorite girl Mazal anyway
no [__] I think they are the
Internet's bravest soldiers like can you
imagine going to the pub and telling
your mates you make ASMR video like that
is all of those girls like any of them
go I don't think many of them like go to
the pub you know they like you mates
explaining to your family to everyone
that you make videos go alien perish
like a seasoned meat right there was a
big scandal in in the commentary
community when it - of the commentary
channels turn out to be having running
secret airs on the song to me what it is
good [__] my favourite they were making
videos on my main channel saying yeah I
struggle to sleep right and I prefer to
sleep when I feel like something's
happening but often can't sleep my
brains too stimulated by a podcast like
a phallus on the organ and I'm just
laughing and getting into it oh I was
always happy yeah you just switch
absolutely it's on good on repeat
whereas ESM or they deliberately tried
to relax you I listen to it just to be
supporting frame is the same thing sorry
sign say I should say
I don't why don't we try that good [__]
I mean it's uncomfortable in a good
gravy I listen to her quite a lot she's
very relaxing and she's very like
spiritual she says things like I know
it's hard sometimes we have all the
pressures on your life and it's just
like you're like this you can't be great
no but like obviously they've got to
save generic things to sort of be broad
but like some of them are just really
good at rolla women and relaxation don't
usually go hand in hand for me so it's a
nice good seeing me thanks for coming I
fought the ancient won't make a pipeline
that podcast of Logan Paul was really
good but some of them some of them are a
bit odd obviously because they've got
their own flavors in that it's a bit
like comedy and commentary and all of
that like you get really different ones
but I just like it fall asleep a lot of
people do to be fair on genuinely this
might surprise me I don't watch the ones
that are sexual because if I'm trying to
go to sleep I don't want to sit there
and go on you know I don't want to sit
there go I wanted one you definitely
crave your pajamas but there are some
that I've got like quite like
girlfriendy qualities where you can sort
of like feel like oh she's nice see you
turned your back on a woman and put ASMR
on as you're trying to fall asleep yeah
the audio hold hobbies yeah well yes
well of course like every youtuber I've
got the iPod Pro what were they called
the iPod
it's a good knife that wasn't fully
visualized I just get two beats pills of
gin
sorry specifically the airport
everything else out the you can't hear
anything else when you've got you mean
people could rob me this idea wash your
dress I've moved into Manchester this
year and I live right by some of you've
ever lived while you have them with your
missus now yeah she comes to visit on
the weekends but during the weekday it's
just any other girl if she if she all
the stairs are welcome do you get a bit
like I think she just goes when she
realized my personality is dog [__] oh
we do stories funny jokes
that's why doesn't make videos anymore
why is he crying like that's nasty my
show second Channel video I don't have a
convey how she really enjoy your second
channel now it's just anyway these guys
I said there's a hotel run that right
outside my window and I mean right now
for you I've been every day and so I
wake up to the sound of crashing glass
on Stone Cold Steve Austin
my roommate is bull-nosed number and PA
says he won't shave his hair again now
he's going that's it it could be a sort
like you said he's got nice eyes and
something a bit like Greek yeah Greek or
Turkish or Mediterranean nothing a
genius to him it's good next year he's
gonna be working with me full-time
really yeah yeah yeah no he's he's gonna
leave the bar I hope lime bar yeah
shouts a lime bar and they had someone
made up they had a terror attack the
other week because and we got stabbed
with a glass but there it wasn't a
terror attack oh I won't read them
stories Laurence you've had an old
friend come and stay with you why you
doing that your old roommate yeah this
is a different one not the Americans of
a viable one night a friend since I was
a kid
oh yeah basically it was a priest friend
and last night I've got a text about
11:30 just saying I'm in London where do
I go
and I was like Travelodge well you
replied because the guy is he got autism
why are we telling this story it's
really interesting I think it's
interesting why god bless subdue your
oldest friend start my video this friend
nobody's got I think he's got us for
autism as oh yeah he keeps on the
down-low but he's also like he's a
really good music artist and so he's he
but he's not recognized in that way
because obviously you know no one gets a
big break but then he just messaged me
basically and said I'm coming to London
but it was very much a message of I'm
coming to London and I'm staying at
yours yeah yeah and I was sort of like
oh I don't know if that's gonna be okay
yeah
brilliant Java sofa yeah yeah yeah yeah
turns up in luck why would I let him
it's not a bed in it so the thing is an
office space only if someone turns up
born I'm coming to yours and you haven't
seen them and I caught was three years
hasn't seen him in three years you
probably go look me it's all for Levin
I'm [__] asleep pal I'll talk to you
tomorrow
I don't link come on then really I like
the idea
this is wouldn't let me but this is what
you and Lawrence will end up murdered
one day if you're not kids like that you
do if someone said that would you book
from my hotel because part me was also
thinking them a hotel they've come to
London they're an adult yeah hotels [__]
know what you say to us you go you can
stay it but you're gonna get rich on the
podcast yeah worried about because he's
also this extremely talented musician
where I'm like wow your music is amazing
what kind of music I think the record
label said he's somewhere between ed
Sheeran and been power power jack was
going on yeah you don't want to know I
knew it is embarrassing cuz a week after
I got that tattoo right so they're you
know I always say it like this so you
know when you write on a bit of paper
and you know you come to the end but you
want to finish the word see you squeeze
it yeah
that's nicely spaced a cure and then
there he's really run out of room whilst
you get that stoppage in the chest
breast of it more fitness yes good yeah
I want to filmed a video for a guy who
one of his friends had this isn't
actually funny
it's actually really sad cancer his
friend had gotten drunk and fallen in a
canal yeah and died yeah two deaths I'm
not even joking fine it literally just
around the corner from here weirdly that
was one of our first podcast I did a
story about cutting the girl up at a
funeral and that was exactly how he died
as well I do have an update on my old
flatmate like the you know the extreme
hardline Muslim girl so the other day
I'm sitting there and I'm typing away
obviously you know working hard PA life
is tricky what would that mean I got a
call and it was my old landlord and he
was like hey Laurence how you don't know
it's a little bit casual no he's not
older she was quite young young yeah
he's coming to my store actually I'm
trying to get the money back so he goes
yeah you remember know all the guy used
to live when I was like yeah yes I
remember him yes we did a really good
podcast okay yeah I've seen it millions
of yeah he's downloaded it tell me find
out the story anyway when he's still
there right do you not throw him out
yeah nice he's still there yeah I'm
taking him to court next week I was just
wondering if you could give me a whole
file of his character for Casey I love
the father you don't have to turn it
we've got you just said so I didn't say
but what Ward is healing want the link
fallout what was what - some even use it
as character reference so the guy was
basically the guy that I live was
basically a [__] and yeah he he was
basically lying and saying the landlord
abused him and that the landlord had
planted bedbugs in his room and the
other gun at one point and shoot he said
shoot me the landlord's actually decided
to play music really loud yes very well
you listening to podcasts again so I
just forgotten Lawrence had one of his
mates stay over and share the room with
him and this guy he got really like
homophobic ly upset it was sort of like
he literally said to me was standing by
the bins outside the flat and I went
yeah by the ways at Frank coming over
tonight he's saying for a nice just
friend and he was like hmm man should
not lie with man and I was like wow aha
sale yeah so we were laying in bed
they're just you know kissing in that
and and then so I'm really hoping that
it's me who's leap like nailed it for
him then he's gonna throw him out the
flowery but over I can't believe he's
still there I applied the long game in
this and so now he's in court I win yeah
Merry Christmas Lawrence Merry Christmas
you filthy [__] I didn't vote a BMP
mate the joke's on you yeah well in yeah
no fair I'll just dipped into the
conservative constituency God we later
Sal I know we've got totally off track I
was expected best youtuber is there any
like this year take him in make sure you
hold it for it's a difficult one isn't
it just call anyone you think about
david dobrik is he does videos which are
short so you can all with your lowest
right - yeah some other youtubers as you
however busy or you what you're doing
okay yeah cool whereas other youtubers
you go from 15 up and 10 am i do that
later actual names like let's go right
Brian you would say I'm looking now I
tell you who I'm disappointed
for just remember boogie2988 yeah sorry
I want him to come bucks what happened
well he's just his channels actually
somewhat vidcom yeah that was and he was
really he was a very bad then really
what and when do you mean I just meant
slate not very well yeah I'm sort of
worried about him he was one of them the
first guys I was like oh I could be an
achiever you know what I mean like he
put it in there was like an original
youtuber I like boogie he's like eh yeah
he's old you give me give me your best
every youtuber this year why do you put
me I mean yes I think JJ gets his own
[__] award at this point so I need to
give it to some actual who might be
watching
I'd say Nico and I feel like I'm a bit
old fun I guess I'm going to say like
I'm just I'm too old first off to say
different name I go with the gasworks
with our hands gasworks is a funny it's
funny it's also got some good detail
it's good podcast like saying [__] Angie
Doakes Wade yeah and she was just in a
flat one night and he was Louella fornia
doing one of those Instagram lives so
she was I think he's really cool and
that what's it called when you like
you're joined and she had a join and he
went is that a joined she went yeah you
right anyway I'll get away with that
[__] and just like the wrong as if he
doesn't smoke doesn't he's a clean
living guy is a for all the brand deals
easier for well he's your favorite
achieve like he's definitely bug does
its basic the one channel I only watch
every single video from his the kickoff
oh yeah Hugh is he a story story Jenny
because I love talk you have to get the
mic out of your mouth yeah
a lot of men have just also woken up now
they're angry no no one [__] look at
JJ beat Logan and q10 Stephen goes have
you won money on it and see this yeah
eight quid the taxman I get that tonight
[Music]
it's anything between Rory and Hugh just
climbing like really angry the other
week I must've been moments where I
thought I feel like Brian's gonna step
in and go alright you need to shut the
[__] up and then he takes them out the
back I'm working with those two his
[__] class like yeah it's good that
you're a set cast now yeah we found the
right blend I think eventually yes you
got an opinion Frank
yeah because like Rory is so [__]
different to Hugh I couldn't have found
two more yeah but ultimately they're
just like passionate about what they see
yeah we all said passionate about what
they say
Jim is how I think I'm really bad
actually actually I think I probably
will say JJ actually if JJ drop distinct
a you know what it is right you know
when you were talking about like say
Maxim it of Newcastle how like you he's
gone beyond a point of being criticized
with the funds I think JJ no one would
even notice if I'm video at this point
like it doesn't matter what he says you
just want to watch it anyway
so for that reason him have you guys
seen that the MMA is on tomorrow for you
yeah I think maybe commentating majority
for certainly not by that by this time
dapper laughs is fine Conor McGregor is
asked to fight can know from the start
because I was very odd Serbian yes right
you finished for me but you see me rot
on the floor I love the fact that the
person fight in Willa to start the fight
NORs this any goals such as punch yeah
yeah
so he takes bribe I this time someone
might die no the latest tweet the
fighters of insurance
that is men's I asked caliber you're
playing football the ever there and I
won't kill him
your insurance so when are I've got
fifty can life insurance just a weight
fifty K is absolutely nothing laughs is
on the bill for I will not be watching I
I sort of been a Manchester Piccadilly
walking around for attention that he
went into TGI Fridays at 8:00 is
feelings yeah
I've been told by him that if I ever
like publicly like talk about what me
and him went through together again that
he's just gonna call me out yeah you'd
literally have nothing on me so yeah now
if he says like he was doing cocaine on
the shoot was he yeah I don't bat an
eyelid at that yeah it is just you know
it's just it for a dapple ah yeah yeah I
never know what dapper means anymore
it's sort of lost all meaning cuz he's a
klutz right all right so I think he's in
my light guy he's alright it's pretty of
you I'll give you actually think he's an
alright guy I see your criticisms of him
laugh I get what you mean I think he's
all right but but sometimes when you've
had your moment just gotta accept it
over and move on with your life and I
think if I'm honest with you that's
probably what I do now like if happens
to me I'll just accept this difficult
that must be though to think and have a
TV show the guide was on top yeah like
he was on itv2 I always liked this big
thing I forgot canceled I was like do I
bring the turtleneck out now he was one
of the originals in the country to
crossover from online to me and even if
it was kind of maybe it was one of the
worst examples absolutely and he sort of
settle spot a little yeah my JJ's
probably done so good a [__] game on
that I felt bad for him because he's a
comedian so jokes part of ejection you
know so I also felt that even because he
was on itv2 giving advice to young men
who were trying to get dates with women
it wasn't like he went out on it on his
own and filmed all this but I can result
proves around him going yeah Bellamy's
fattening his hair come up to him with
this idea well I think he maybe could
have pitched him they've come to him
with that yeah we don't know but I did
hate I love mum and dad so talking about
- it was crossing over to the mainstream
yeah did I pave the way I think you did
Jack now I suppose the big brother when
you were you nearly did Big Brother yeah
I bet I did a trial week but they didn't
tell me that I was a trial list so when
I was in there
I thought there was a chance that I
could be on that even though on launch
day it's usually punch night isn't it I
went up and there was a guy just
hammering like doing the same what was
it was it quite intense living in a
house with other desperate wannabes yeah
yeah it was really they all called me
Paul because they said it's the whitest
name they could they kicked you out but
have I ever told you about the my
technique when I went in to make
everyone kind of like respect me no I
really want to know yeah many many moons
ago me and my dad would watch a big
brother and we came up with this idea
that and I said if I ever get in there
I'm gonna do it now foolproof so yeah it
made it work himself commonest like
watermelon we can get this to ten
minutes that would be a great little
clip well that's some strong [__] there
Brian
that's gifs no nibbles don't need it oh
good old T here to see will not be all
high 14 yeah it reminds me of when I was
in the crew ywa
I keep it quite thick why did you smoke
in seven runs you smoke you say I'm an
extremist I'm actually worried about
wills healthier yeah
it's serious you are pure weed yeah as a
pure ganja I've got to get the [__]
not virgin train anymore because I've
shagged the Avanti tre stereo true Jordi
CBD coming Suzi or whatever you were
talking about before we all die yeah I
was in a Big Brother house for a week
all right
and when you're in there sometimes when
you want to get when you want to go in
and speak to the diary room they won't
call you right so when you see on the TV
show it's like can Jack come to the door
oh yeah they only do it if you're not
near the door because I've always you
just expect so you just sit outside I'm
not mean oh right so it's what I did
right so when you're going this welcome
pack right this is actually a half
decent story I'll promise you I'll get
there was Florence so you're at this
point you're not even making with your
comment sort of slating relation about
big brother yes I am I ran away from the
door so they vote so they actually had
to call me in so everyone knew I was
going in and on the way in there's would
like a welcome pack and I stole like a
sheet from the welcome good luck well in
and up they would like Jack would you
want to talk about and I was like
nothing I just want to sit in it for
like 10-15 minutes so like okay so we
just had a normal chat they have to
commit well from that yeah yeah and then
I come out and there was this one like
kunti woman in there that no one likes
I'll come out and I'll be like it in the
house yeah in the house I've come back
to the room they're all sat around they
don't know I've got this sheet they all
they know is I've been called in they
didn't know that I press the button so
I've gone into the bathroom and I've got
these two toilet rolls and I've gone Big
Brother collected that and everyone's
like [__] this mean it meant nothing
then I went up to the conscience one in
there now when number one and just
wrapped her up in this toilet row and
she stood there like I went I know I
went right who else wants the other one
they went no no and then for the whole
week they were just kissing my ass cuz
they thought I had some power to get him
gone and then on the last day before we
were due to go I just got around the
porn went yeah it means fuck-all you're
really nice do you would have been
classy big brother like any approaches
to do like the jungle irony that
[__] would you actually how'd you do
first though or the winner what my
problem we'll enjoy sweet about
McPartlin far too many times for me -
yeah Oh Caroline Caroline Flack beating
a fellow oh yeah yeah tender require
violence should be a fella yeah I did
say that but when it comes to I'm asleep
I've already I've been there done that
so I'm not gonna do it again
didn't you do that once that's right yes
there's a guy from the violent he's gone
blind have you seen it with the eye hey
what happened with him the biggest ally
of skins it's more than an hour why see
your hey twice you know you idiot you
look strong party it was there puck Wow
no one did the phone I have it yeah I
don't get for their mates gather round
[Applause]
Toby Fiore just three the shelf I want
to celebrate in the air with the East
Josh Denzel to Dabo via was it no no no
someone popped the cork hit him and he
was like [__] then another one hit him
directly in the eye and just ripped like
so his eyes look like that is horrible
but he's isn't someone treat him like a
bit of a probably that was that was a
Josh Johnson who treated him a bit of a
he basically immediately after yeah I
don't know Josh turns out this or
Instagram he looks like the smuggest
prick you've ever seen wrong every
picture he's in Dubai on a [__] you
know rubble Ray's shoebox and have got
him on every [__] talk yeah
head-to-head it's not peace off get
somebody what she knows what they're
talking about yeah yeah easier Lawrence
that things Eddie Firth coming on the
podcast yeah Joanne Tyson when I've got
nothing to do with Eddie yeah that was
probably the most awkward moment we had
in the whole podcast because what we
think of that because also Eddie had
come in and gone yeah he calls me at
3:00 a.m. and stuff when we were like
good banter they're sort of going back
as I get how Eddie can be a you know a
bit of a smarmy real-life did he came
across you have really like nice energy
he's got a lot of charisma yeah much
mated Tyson going to be honest with you
I think I totally found it easy to deal
with at the time and I was like right
and only afterwards someone tweet
doesn't go well the way you handle that
I thought was that a moment and like no
it was a bit of it always it strange is
it cuz you'd go oh so the way you did
that you felt like this I need to go no
no no maybe strange with that Tyson
Highbury you're not talking to a normal
person so you're not gonna like them
there's people who are you can maneuver
a certain way you could manipulate a bra
or you can take them down a road of
questioning you can't do that a Tyson
food no yes okay
come on to answer questions and some
people just want to say you don't know
what you get days but what buzz words in
questions and then just go yeah what
what was is that like [__] hilarious
came across a really lovely guy's dog
was talking with him he had a really
lovely handshake is that ball for them
at the end said to me like how good time
nidhogg you can really want to them no
genuine he said and he went I'd love to
come on the podcast I was like right he
was a BBC good boxer wasn't it yeah I
believe are Liotta not Tyson I think it
was Ollie actually dodge dip my name is
cuz yeah if you're a bite of the block
he's a [__] ton he's dad is massive
and he trains a zombie fury now cuz he's
his half-brother yeah you gonna have
some [__] hands to deal with Tyson and
I taught Tyson I was really proud of
getting him on cuz he pops in it like
the third podcast I was talking about
getting Tyson Fury on yeah it was like
hundreds a year before you got him on
you were talking about yeah I rang them
up man ahadees phone number you found
the toast of you know holy [__] I'm
actually fruit was answer machine Mahina
thought this isn't the way I want to get
a [__] podcast now it's for you and
also that was when he was on the worst
part of his low absolutely it was right
on this yeah I really appreciating me
voicemails Brian about the Christmas or
girls anybody remember what we said I do
I actually wanted like hit you have a
few questions because should don't like
because I think you went through that
rough patch at the star didn't you and I
feel like that was I think the middle of
the year particularly was just a
nightmare
yeah and that was yeah I had a good stop
cuz the Saudi air we did chievous Ian
right I'm like smashable
yeah yeah I've got you're right Brian in
front of us I'm like this is humble like
this is an idol of mine yeah and I've
got him giving me like all this emotion
and then I've got Gervase dropping
knowledge on his thing like yeah
you know it's like she got along with us
no mate so genuinely I've never been he
was the most intimidating podcast I've
ever done was reverse because Thea Baker
is alive right I'm on an intellectual
level I've all like he could make me
look so stupid I'm sure when I got there
he had a he had a driver ready
you could go anybody yeah yeah like
that's right I forgot I've got a parking
ticket when he died never got so close
speak thrice never because I was at his
premiere for afterlife yeah and I always
I won't not watch that because of Ed
it's a bit hard oh no generally is the
only I've tried like in a theater out
after lime and spice has got me though
he was right there he's right there and
I times one make James I've brought to
me as my plus-one to premiere on a when
I'm gonna say oh I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna [__] up the coaching one now's not
the time you get another chance I never
I don't have a chance with that because
I was gonna bottle speaking to her but
you read this is Stephen and the future
of comedy right this guy is the future
I'm Ricky he's not make it on TV mr.
Ricky I was intimidated um because I
just wanted to make sure I didn't help
meself now relax them how just yeah he
makes you feel so he's like your
granddad's it's a special she always
wears the same clothes and then it's
close yeah doesn't it it's mental he's
always wearing the same clothes right
now he's a corpse he makes an effort
with you to educate you younger man like
he's he's telling you things in your
life uh-huh like I found myself being
like wow I really fought with tiny
wheels before you stick it I just got
off the podcast I mean yeah any a sort
of laughter jokes as well I've just been
a bit more copper common room yes a year
later he went on Jerry Seinfeld's
comedian cigars getting coffee
mmm and Jerry singers she laughs at
normal people's jokes and Ricky goes
yeah sometimes I sort of feel like I
have
to me feel better no sight well with was
he is he actually laughing oh did he
actually find it funny we did get a few
like yeah house that was fasted when I
first ever interviewed him I was
[__] my yeah yeah and I was sat
there and I cut this out of the video it
was terrible the first four minutes was
terrible because I was like doing it I
was trying to be like this kind of like
deadpan kind of like guy they won't like
a podcast I was like I have to be funny
now
yes it's cringing you know I said to him
I was like come egg is a cuddle and I
[__] you not you didn't move right so I
went and then I'm like [__] myself
even more
they're my last few jokes find out the
hens he's doing that laughs - so it's
given me a bit of courage but we watch
it back in the editor like that's not a
real laughs not real laugh and then at
the end when it's like few improv little
bit I'd tell you in lines yeah tell in
the Edit there the game lines and
looking back I got more of that yeah I
was in fact the premiere halfway free we
still not answer questions pointed mean
he's laughed at me read you back and I
was all what's really funny that if you
did back Ricky Gervais is canceled if I
could never do what like you three do in
terms of interviewing hard big
personalities that you actually look up
to because I breathe now Shelby Alonso I
was held that we had a great time
because I went join you were when you
take it apart in the Istanbul pearl to
shoot only when there is actually what I
love is there's some great pictures of
Steven during the shabby alone beaten
you just go in heads TT just looking off
into the distance like oh he go [__]
you know you talk about that bit the
nervy bit yeah this is the first year
where I've interviewed people who I'd
know I should feel something
nothing like an Tyson Fury nothing like
I didn't I was proud of myself but I
thought nor fear nor nerves
nothing is the first time where I was I
like yeah was it different with Logan oh
that was their like mitts
that's okay oh the first time I met JJ I
was [__] like this guy's I looked up
the JJ so much I was like you are the
[__] Gort me JJ makes it so easy on
people I loved when we did the happy
hour with him he was great even
afterwards I don't generally spoke to me
and was like very much personable and I
[__] hate when you get guest on and
like because it's my show they'll chat
to me and then the co-hosts they just
they don't give a [__] who's actually
given time to people as well I saw him
in a completely different light I was
like you actually a sound [__] it's
nicely like you felt like he actually
wanted to be there yeah my podcast that
we did with them was 2018 7017 that was
that was his I think that was his first
podcast in a week later he blacked
everything out on social media and quit
and I thought he did the same thing we
did half yeah yeah I wish we would turn
up the studio and I turn to Jack and I
go you just it just made this profile
picture black I went where he doesn't
want to be on it he was voted worksheet
yee-hoo so what was your most Awkward
podcast moment this year we haven't had
that many awkward podcast this year know
if you have this year ninja Tyson Fury
Richard raised in Riley I think the
whole Broadway not was just mental he is
ahead what the Brody one yeah really I
don't know well I also said that I'm not
like mental to the point where it's like
a memorise me like filthy Frank if it
was like even more off-kilter you read
social situations and then for some
weird reason his brain works out the
opposite thing that you're supposed to
do in that situation
all of him did you know that's really
weird actually because I got on
exceptionally well with him which is why
I was quite upset yeah it's really funny
because because I often people say that
about you and then after the podcast we
like go out with people it's so funny
like even with Apple laughs afterwards
we weren't for it
and we were all sitting there i sat next
to him and we were having a laugh we
were like having a good time I think
because I speak in a certain way and you
know this anyway sometimes I just come
across in a bad way I was really nice
when he fell out with you because or
whatever happen with you have a
standpoint I can't say the Edward I get
I get respect I think as a creator you
totally get this YouTube site yeah I
just think the way your comment is
totally wrong he goes I say the n-word
so you know it liberate we've had this
debate with him though and obviously I
think a lot of people actually it's the
worst podcast because people thought we
were bullying him or they thought
there's nothing at yeah and maybe that's
our responsibility as podcast makers to
be like give the context and be like
look we spoken what's Brody off the
podcast and maybe that didn't come
across in the podcasting are always what
was going on for you on that day in
terms of you not feeling well
what the boos everyone so I had the
shits yeah so I turned up I've got the
shits
I'm meeting Dan Bilzerian I'm the last
interview of the day which they told me
it would be the other way around
I'm in his [__] hotel room I'm not in
the situation I'd like to be in he he is
sick of his life he [__] hates his
life because he's just had an hour of
grilling of some woman for degrading
women also for me personally I'm just
like yeah [__] me I said I just downed a
load of whiskey and my [__] this I'm
gonna go and trying and you know is a
that probably was one of the hardest
interviews I've ever had in terms of
making a guest actually get involved
yeah and also not [__] yourself at
the same time me I couldn't believe it I
heard about Taylor more gym and like
half about Louis I'm not even kidding
i I bought you that and then oh yeah you
are our cameraman is a job when most
normal people take one Brian's taken for
Q naught it is at work though
I made it through that positive yeah a
podcast was challenging in many ways
yeah I said a misfolding on it maybe
hard to have a good podcast as well as
because you can't put it on and when
there they were sort of like it closed
off I think if you're in their house
he's got so much power heating and also
it was also that he was never willing to
see you know with his mouth open
yeah that the what would you call it the
kickback from the Brody one I found that
completely wrong
yes the damn one I was like yeah I don't
get it I didn't enjoy it my safari in a
row there was three in a row and all the
comments were terrible damn one I didn't
like like from anyone's right I don't
know a broken one because they were
saying that so for the damn one they
were saying that you were just agreeing
to stuff
and then with the Brody one they were
saying that you were bullying him but I
was thinking this this guy like and this
is just my opinion here right he knows
that I'm not fan of him you were
whenever he was getting out of control
you were giving him great feedback which
is what really yeah yeah it's like you
can't win because one minute
the Leo knew you're doing this to Dan
which I thought you were bit this then
when it clears the Brody you've got the
other way and you get backlash they're
like yeah you might be fun people just
listen hard is the interview people at
the comments I've seen three in a row I
like you guys obviously but I'm seeing
nothing comment I was like that's so
funny because I like the Brody one was a
weird one in the first place because
Brody's a very different energy in real
life to the energy of the ears on camera
and if you speak to him off camera is
very different to the waves Lee is on
camera we're not off covers the sabers
yeah you might wanna yeah and I I think
it was very different
I thought it's just he was promised home
don't know if you could chat on any
level yeah and that's not quite that's
what I didn't quite understand was like
that the whole what was going on with
you and I didn't know whether he was
saying it because maybe he wanted to you
know mention you in the podcast those
kind of things but the damn one was just
it was just a bizarre podcast in general
I think on that day and then what was
the what happened what was there was
three on the collar on the comment
this is the year of like hated the most
I know people who have been counseled
previously which is why I aim is I set
to work and so I offer them well on
point she said I don't I said I've
actually been a lot happier not making
videos like there's like no pressure on
yourself to be a role model be right all
the time yeah and I said to oh I won't I
don't know if I'm gonna come back and we
win
you're a [__] idiot you have to come
back tomorrow so when you just read the
comments how do you know who's a fan and
who's not because happy we had it where
someone's like the MgO and gone you're a
con and then you've got your apply I
just agree on that really nice pasta for
me personally very negatives down you
know if I have nice nice nice horrible
horrible horrible I automatically feel
more impact I'm sure it means nothing no
no dude when I think when I did start
and I did stand up yeah someone wasn't
laughing that's what you're holding it
on yeah so what didn't laugh at a joke
it's like what's wrong with that joke
yeah human nature isn't it my brain and
I'm realizing this now like I'm before
this I was working offshore mentioned at
the table times did you off sure again
just diving yeah watch that so negative
yeah I was being judged by 12 guys
around me for my job was [__] and like
I'd get the feedback I'd get on with it
I change I am my our brains are not made
to be [__] having millions of people
judging us the way that it is so like if
you're not dealing with it as I haven't
dealt with it well in the last year
they're not normal
no I'm saying yeah I've dealt with it as
if I'm alive but I certainly haven't
like felt if I also think there's an
element of because the way that you
dealt with it and decided to approach it
head-on and laugh at are a fraud should
head on and drink and smoke as much as
is that escapism isn't it yeah yes but
as much as you drank and smooth like
there were let's be our first stop do it
yeah
but no one seeing me like I've seen that
shut up Robin I'd say in that day in
those days we spent about three three
hours on the phone perfectly every day
just talking uh not not talking down a
legend of him but just sort of talking
through what was going on yeah between
now whether we're talking business we're
talking like how the [__] am I gonna
like rebuild like yeah well respected
but so can I just say that here's what I
thought about Brian in that time was
there was an interesting point where it
wasn't just about that and we actually
had to keep the business going we had to
make some business decisions and he did
just put all of that aside and it was
like [__] this like who cares in a way
and within those hours where we were
talking on the spent a lot of time that
but there were times where it was just
like we could actually talk about
business we could talk about where we
were gonna go and it was almost like
this isn't gonna it was never you never
spoke about will she just quit or
whatever yeah maybe there one or two
miles for you know I wasn't think about
quitting YouTube I was talking about
quittin life Lee yeah at that point I
was like this I I hate life yeah I knew
I would come back reassurance though
yeah I knew I would come back from it
but I don't want I don't want to come
like did you got a point we you seen so
many you should be come back from that
stuff well I with me I went I looked and
I went I know I can come back easily oh
that's not a problem it was more I was
like I don't know if I could come back
from it personally I could just crack on
better yeah it's not really the same as
actually like getting your entire life
situation though where you also your
channel was quite critical of other
people yeah I know that's why I was a
big struggle for me I was like I'll I'd
never look to anybody who criticized me
and went well they're wrong you know and
if it was me I'd probably make a video
on it when you [__] up oh yeah as soon
as it happened not even when I said
stuff whereas like as soon as my mates
or Gwen
oh yes only so it's been accused of this
I went oh this isn't gonna go well
because it doesn't ever go well there's
no way you come out but you every time I
sing as soon as they told me I knew it
was all over right because they called
me and when all we can tell you we can't
my one well now you've said that when it
all comes out eventually it will be
either you did so site where you don't
say sign so there's no winning there so
did you wrestle with any level of like
guilt of what you'd actually done yeah
why didn't she go oh yeah let's just
make some tweets about him move on I was
like why aren't the police involved and
I mean ever he goes the police will be
involved eventually but I feel like
you'd be doing this type of people and
there's the line of work that especially
mean you are in you you're almost
obliged to talk about that thing which
has our own downfall because when we had
our gang which could have so easily like
I'm not just saying this for the cameras
it could have been sorted out so a
five-minute car because we are these
kind of like or these commentary
channels and especially being around you
I read and there's nothing on you but
what you do who's same as me I felt like
I have to make a video about this well I
thought people around you go well people
around you like well if you really think
this guy is illegitimate you should do
is to do he's very much a commentary
thing that's why I try to move towards
like the people like Cody Cohen L Miller
are doing she look of course they'd
never have these problems which I'm not
making serious like takedown videos on
people and it's highly on that other way
don't live with the Jake poor thing like
he's called them out and the red Jake
Paul converted him it's like it's just
jokes but he's a hundred percent true it
is just jokes but then to someone else
that he's actually spoken about they
don't have the comedy band that he does
know they take in a bad way yeah that's
part of it is I think a few people that
we've criticized from true news have
just had a really shitty sense of humor
and not even able to take the jokes yeah
and they've reacted in such a way well I
didn't take the joke when you said that
you just tweeted me that one thing that
wasn't a joke but at that point we were
we were on good terms
yeah we were chattin and then he's
tweets me that and because I know that
you take the piss in your videos I've
completely seen that side of your
personality and God he must mean it like
this then it's happening even though you
don't know you didn't I don't know it
but so then I've done that video and
then it's blown up and it's like this is
only happening because we are like
communication yeah but I genuinely have
always liked you always always rated you
as a person always but it just it gets
blown up because rather
it's always it's always communication
especially when you have jobs like ours
and there's so much social pressure yeah
si with the stuff half of me it wasn't
just like oh we might got a keys of some
really terrible things and then like a
confront areas right now twenty other
full-time youtubers one if you don't go
this way we all think it's this way they
go you know like you've got a you've got
to really join in on this side like this
is the way that it's like this is the
way you think it's gonna go and and you
often get it going oh man there's a lot
to gain from this nobody sort of
thinking that but it's one those things
where when you suddenly have like twenty
people call you up it's like a
terrifying experience and that happens a
lot you see behind the scenes I think
people don't realize there's a lot of
things app and where five or six people
get together and go oh man II meant like
this and a lot of people comment the
called come to you specifically because
you are that guy yes I know the amount
of gossip you know as mental the first
things I when the stuff out me have them
like three months before anything right
and then people came to me and I when I
when I let you remember the first time I
said to everyone are you only coming to
me because you know that I will feel
responsible if I now know this it's hard
to make videos and other people it make
sure it won't be John - yes sort of bad
if you're making videos on people every
three days if you're making people just
do like clickbait and stuff over three
days when somebody goes this sheet you
were most sexually assault people you
don't say that's going in the intro all
the time saying that this makes YouTube
has done this than this I'm innocent
yeah I mean that was done as a [__]
about something when even when I did
that live stream about you as like a
retaliation people watching that good
right Lauren dude what the [__]
people whine said true news is gonna be
good
people like Ella Billy yeah there were
people in my comments find the stuff you
like well you should make a video on it
and then I even I back then there's like
I've never made a video on a friend of
mine ever even for anything we're going
that far no things that you do where you
go I'm not gonna make a big deal right
I'm just gonna do a run on Twitter
that's inevitably gonna get clipped up
by someone else and re-upload it's a
it's at like moment of weakness where
you feel like oh it's just it's just
Twitter saying people it's all about
everything we've talked about lads it's
about being the 20-something year old
youtuber special issues between you guys
and Igor and not wanting to back down
and not wanting to be seen in a certain
way and it's about growing up and
realizing this is not that deep as it
yes a that difficult though because
let's face it the audience isn't older
they're not skewed older so that the
encouragement is gonna be to act in that
younger almost not immature but like
less it's that's what I feel like like
drama is just like currency it's almost
like but if it is if it is manufactured
like what Jake Paul does then you're
good but when it becomes real no what
you do and then when you said do a roast
I was like that's the perfect way to
draw that the day it happened I was like
I'm calling Steven trice on the day
generally for hours I remember sit that
going how could I wish I'd have done
that I'll be honest though Steven you
handled Brian's dm's really well it was
rainy here I'm go to the toilet right
now the best thing was at that point or
a girl in there Steve the best thing was
we I guess we always had a plan where we
instantly knew there had to be that
level hmm but it was when Steven texts
me out of nowhere with some of the jokes
and just when I can contribute I was
like it wasn't even like we genuinely we
hadn't gone to him and gone put a
tribute piss out of him now hey I've got
some good ones now as like he's ready
he's not in a good headspace never mind
yeah these ten jokes I was the perfect
way yeah it couldn't have gone like this
and I genuinely don't think there's any
other YouTube other than Brian that
could have handled it that well yeah
because of what you have is a yeah no
[__] way uses monkey emotion it's
real dealing it's not use monkey emojis
I don't believe it Brian do you admit in
in just the worst way to using monkey
emojis I see your figure to Crimea I
support my sister not like I've done and
I was like yeah so I you make it might
be seen something that she was like yeah
no it's real sorry sorry I choose I
course it's real and it's you like I was
like okay yes this is gonna be a [__]
weather then oh he's my boy he's my boy
he's alright that's another thing you
come from BG media do you genuinely
enough MA without Geo blown away the
[__] I'd be come into you Joey deserve
to be in the pop you didn't send email
this is my other photo seen Alex's
changes for a second Muse like he's one
of my best mates Gio spends so much time
with Brian I feel like these two are in
symbiosis the second side of it is since
joining us we found out that Gio is
probably one of the funniest guys on the
planet to do your Tyson Fury he's so
good impressions does he do your face
episode road
I'd love to shoot it but I turned up
before comes a setup stand there and
look at it it was good though Gio's got
I don't know whether it's because you've
watched a lot of Brian yeah you've got a
fantastic sense of humor to the point
right now I'm like he should be on
camera do you know what login sort of so
yeah we just bring the team out
generally hilarious [__] anyway in
some people worked hard [__] geo
deserves a lot of credit
yeah shut shut out the geo here's my boy
there's also a big side of it where I
think you two work extremely long hours
together which was me it's funny though
I don't think I'd be here if it wasn't
for will Maude what's up number them
these days oh no idea
may I have a child you could see Sophie
I spin on every lovely corner it's grim
up north from channel 4 yeah done and
that's how I found you know it was the
Afghan that documentary I never can you
treat you I saw this rubout will is like
obviously I was like and do my film
degree and then will made the video Bob
Apple dry media and at that point it was
just a Blackpool thing and we'll sort of
made it into like maybe - yeah it's one
of those things where all my friends at
home if I go back they go or you know
will anneal off those Blackpool videos
yeah I was not a part of that so don't
probably say stuff nailed it for me I
mean recently it's been the tip it's
been the tick-tock stuff about you right
you're a big before because my mate
showed me it when you have a hundred
thousand viewers really talking about
page where all this stuff what made you
blow up what was it it was the first
thing always every glide if you go on
Twitter you say my name is there I took
my shirt off for an easy on video people
that's when people start shooting in
didn't what's his name
that make up blood p.m. you vote your
dick or something now say that wasn't
meant to be public knowledge that was a
second a second Channel video will Annie
quite clear we struggling for these at
once say for I'll just mention his
private T ends of that blight quietly
and I remember I remember the moment
where me and James we talked quite a bit
and he's quite a nice bloke aims at the
lash machine will posted this videos
well posted this video and remember
there was a joke in it before all that
might cause a bit problems but it was
only only realized it was an issue when
I got my message from James and it was
just the YouTube URL link
and before I'd even clicked on it I was
instantly thinking what is this question
mark and that's when I knew it was over
what is it was does he ever spoken to
you since then no no we met our boys we
yeah we just like going like after work
but not many words exchanged if you know
what I mean no no no we don't agree had
a decent conversation about all that RT
Westbrook stuff because I was just
starting why not how do you pronounce
all this tardy stuff I just can't take
question could open some great shoes you
really rate yourself as a podcast day
but I've got a girl uestion actually
question it's just asking question more
than the guys know no [__] coming
here asking my questions you know it is
right yeah I'll be shot there yeah
Laurens a bait to fair play right we
still have the question though do we
have the question what is the best video
released this year you have to pick one
oh I've got mine
you should rewind and it's not
interested but they david dobrik when he
got really married Jason doesn't watch
Dave watch videos to say I bought my do
today a car straight with you Brian I'm
[__] waiting for that video alright
so did you know David Everett was an
angry birds T was he hey I did actually
see that I was speaking of Angry Birds
tarty best YouTube video this year hello
are you still doing the affair you just
mentioned it I'm trying to think like
who the boy God I I made a mistake
blooper reel would you say about these
bisexual evil again well that I haven't
made my genuinely not a million miles
away from saying wills Hawaii video I
know but my issue is my video I were
piggies also on this pool the roast was
four of us made into it
yeah sided that day was probably not for
me giving yeah some of the kind of the
joke is something I've recently been
told that I would be unusual because I
told the sidemen that they were in
special needs class in private school
just the a an agent I was meant to
really can't use you because we think
that's a that you don't like kids with
disabilities I am up in my [__] house
mate alright I got I use this I got
toddler was too close
England rugby union shirt what for video
yeah no no for ready for a [__] brand
deal they went you to controversial good
I was like thank you you guys are
getting this and I'm allowed because I'm
a video
we can I think my favorite [__]
candle Nikko's fight video when he got
my one this year generally was like the
air that's shinin on my mom's video it
was a good is it also the aspect that he
stood next to a guy who could knock him
out also I want to I want to mention not
too much but for the that was the moment
I never knew about seven yeah tell you
it I never knew about that's how I
didn't even know I was watching that the
other night as much as you listen to
ASMR was to get all this to a podcast
for a bit and then I was like I'll go to
sleep and listening to Brian's podcast
yeah that was a lot of people said that
was the let me get off the planet moment
like it opens your mind up to sober a
lot of people talk about how when you
hear things like that you just don't
want to believe it because yeah it makes
you go the third tower in the name of
people told not to talk about
conspiracies but [__] it were here yeah
that was there was three towers that
went down that day two of them are hit
by planes one of them went down in
freefall speed and people had already
report on the news yet going to help
yeah maybe say news it was already
reported down and there was still
started by the news report mental I feel
like this Jeffrey Epstein stuff like are
we clearly [__] killed himself that's
added more weight to everything it would
never be vandalize my Christmas I'm poet
she's yet to arrive has there was a guy
who in there a Jeffrey Epstein jump
that's because the Christmas show
paedophile us my dad
that's not funny who said there's a guy
who looked into a rack my mate told me
and he found out that there was no
weapons there there was no reason to
invade and he hung himself in the forest
look important vlog it was too early for
Fox
but apparently yeah yeah he killed
himself when he found out there's no
reason to invade I will make sure his
channel is at the moment I wanted to
change the name to everyday epstein
because he must have been 200 it's just
every time I got out like he's churning
out that's why I got in so they're the
conspiracy very podcast this is the
person I could go down I was like oh I
don't want to come back because this is
too scary the world is scary I don't
have anything
loving it doesn't seem like a sort of
drug dealing may when you give him a
hole it is like you can tell he really
like it's full of like goodness he's
very nice energy yeah
yeah it's I forget completely that he
did like ten years in prison trust
moving hundreds of thousands of dollars
of each show ever it's just jokes yeah
yeah Bob it's an interesting one he's my
top podcast guest of all time
really yeah now he's made it that was
generally was one of my favorites it's a
show like yeah it's not quite for your
Baker though rule is I rate him for the
ship balls of just saying the stuff he
said like he just comes out in the
simulator Epstein's house yes knock on
the door it just makes me feel yeah he
doesn't give a [__] he makes like our me
who's the guy who wall keep bringing up
all the time he makes me go look like
like a safe playing guide yeah yeah
he'll go like P doors houses and just
like
long comment enjoy that your daddy went
to the Epstein house didn't even EMA got
the videos what there's a picture of
Prince next to a banister in a house
with the the girl who was like whatever
I don't know how old she was and trying
to quite find out like was that the
house was it Geoffrey Epstein's house he
went to the house he got the woman
opened the door
there it is there it is like you've got
the proof of it the cleaner I reckon I
think Sean that good as as much as
hearts in the right place got a cleaner
killed because the cleaner opens the
door and Sean's there going anyway talks
like Paul McCartney and then he goes
there it is there it is and MacLean is
like what what but he's like come around
this side and then the white banisters
right there and the cleaners just going
can I help you it's Mullen when a prince
of this country can be basically outed
as a [__] P door and everyone's like
yeah whatever
like watch that I wish I knew if there's
ever a video for you to make bro their
Redemption I came in Piers Morgan should
have been cancelled two years ago but I
feel like he's got so much dirt on these
higher robes that he must be topping
scandal people with like dying kids and
knowledge it no and it was pretty much
yeah whatever whatever exact this Mendel
if someone should have been got rid of
and it's still there on mainstream media
there's a [__] Asian pride time
starting in Norway Morgan's like in a
bar in London it's like you know
drinking his sorrows away insane I was
once really [__] at my job I'd love
Piers Morgan to just end up taking all
the Arsenal fan TV or something yeah
yeah postgame troops what what are your
thoughts on the match genuinely you must
have a lot on JJ's given K to do those
in I was that's what I said to him is I
was I makes me feel really uncomfortable
when I watch Jay Jay on that when it's
like
piers more for you Mook yeah how much
money do you unbuttoning the box
very much success photos yeah Jonah raid
Thank You raid fellow legends
that's right shadow legends am i right
yes is there any more questions about
that youtuber Lester of you're out of I
think we might have well he said best
video and I'm like what did you see that
Taliban Charlie I just ran like the best
of the Year China more job but I've
never seen many of her videos often when
she's chilling on the bed with Jake does
she really deserve that I suppose the
marriage thing was like a big deal but
the way you've got to decide that stuff
on which is not always the biggest about
when it comes to ship is do you write oh
my god you did really well this year in
terms a lot views and attention or do
you write oh my god this video is really
good but nobody cares yeah and the
Streamy Awards on its America really
isn't any award show is [__] like
the real metrics akeem [__] says it is
views and subscribers like five million
views that's it like you make good
videos more people watch them it's it
really people pretend that it doesn't
correlate but make it a good video to a
degree no making a good video is making
a good YouTube video yeah I think you
can get me oh no they Envy somebody he's
got five million views of video who
quite clear hates what they're doing
yeah if I see somebody's getting two and
a half like that they're not quite low
top top tier but they're not like where
I'm at they like in that they're that
middle bracket like when I see those
people I'm like you're quite clearly
doing very well but you're not like
quite you're not selling yourself out I
show you so when it comes to like being
some movies and music the people who are
usually number one movie they're number
one music or the other ones who sell the
most albums i music they usually like
mainstream like yeah i usually go for
the people who are like in the bracket
below and i'm pretty much the same on
your dribbling bracket who are always
it's like you've done just enough i've
gone well play for playing the game but
also you've said i need to quite clearly
see you're still very much being true to
yourself that's odd okay see now stop
right in his prime for example when he
wasn't like huge huge numbers but he was
like authentic he was making cool [__]
like that's the kinda created my Alec
ones who are creating pressure yeah
they're being true themselves within me
as well even even game channels the
gaming channels when they first start it
was like you're making videos on the
site that most people would laugh at and
it's doing really well for yourself but
it's nowadays a gaming channel now is
seen as like everybody does realize so
it's always I think if you're one of
those people you go
he's quite clearly a pioneer that's
always white like an award I think we've
got we've got in the made - I think we
were in the top - for the fame have to
be merry you have to be American though
now on streamys we're not even in the
run and you have Joe Rogan wasn't even
top five for the Streamy Awards I was
like well he weren't that impulsive yeah
I mean yeah it was if it was properly
met but for creative no hmm what if we
came back and went hey guys it's the
true Gordy here be a great moment which
what would you like to do next Stephen
what's your course in asking this for
five years thank you thank you with all
of the support just a minute I'm radio
for am i right I read the support from
Willis there's a lot of moral support
next year I just need to go proper like
2016 Stephen tries when I just tried to
make a video a week hit the million give
up run off into the sunset with a you're
gonna do Tyson Fury on you when you hit
the million that's when you're like it's
all downhill from this is where I'm
walking down Dean's getting Manchester
going England
you should go the by barnum read a bunch
of funny songs anyone [__] this YouTube
stuff you stole you when you get on the
podcast please bring me back for that
one Stephens doing stand-up ladies and
I've read some you stand up finally and
you'll see on the will knee and Stephen
tries to do this time no more charity
yeah we get paid up front yeah I only
we've not done at all yeah there's a lot
of funds unit uh yeah I think the
logistics book Ryan off yeah that the
big sickness though yeah it looked at
was very good Manchus
was good Birmingham was good but in big
cities Oxford could get [__] uh-huhs
can't Belfast ah oops which Wow I mean
you castlemartin Asia even when we did
our show in front 25 people we're doing
a show even in front of 25 people was so
much more rewarding than making love
yeah yes
my two best moments of the year was at
summer in the city they got me to do a
live show I planned [__] nothing went
out did an hour we did that they really
do let's do a live show Jack they told
me like maybe a day before was it run by
Fame MMA you know someone the city to
use I enjoy doing those so I enjoyed the
meetups in terms of speak to people base
its it feels dirty in a way the way they
put you in a little aisle and you happy
yeah yeah the fact that youtubers don't
get I don't know do they get paid for
that now yes should get paid for that
because the [__] event of some agents
should get paid or they're paying okay
another event great event and resonate
Big Ups resonates moment can we go to
the point right summer in the city are
just [__] con merchants and they will
use your brand to sell tickets to people
who don't have any budget to pay they
take advantage of the fact that they
were the first events so they're like oh
well this is like the one that everybody
used to go to so you should still come
to this for sure the after pie the
after-party they talked about we were on
this [__] cruise ship okay you have
you have to go upstairs to the top floor
then instead of getting a free drink
whatever you have to tweet about what
was sponsoring the the pie Oh mother Lea
- that's a tweet hashtag Mamma Mia -
free drink and that was it [__] and I
was invited to that and I ignored the
emails because they beat it out all this
is what the ice from
just gonna look like and they'd like
this proper ice Frank look like in the
gym ice rink and then everybody got
their I posted the pictures and it's
like somebody put a lot of pieces o
singular penguin in the middle it was so
you can't you can't believe it
it's just the most and people always are
you got to go meet your fans but it's
like I don't want to promote an event
where it's quite clear they don't give a
[__]
it is horrible isn't it cuz we we went
out there we deliver specific meet and
greet
we just got pinned against the wall so
we did a live show and then no people
who basic saying they were to meet three
members of EXO and so you're Hubbell
Utes you do you but not me no clearly
not
I mean do you enjoy that when there's a
line of people I like speaking to people
I prefer it when I've got a sit-down
know like comment is not because I was
standing up for hours and I was like
getting kind of tired you just finish it
oh yeah the hours do go on I actually
get a bit of a like buzz off of meeting
the funds and that not that's the bit I
was abroad that's the bit I enjoyed like
you know what I was talking about you
cons the you know talk about how I'm
disconnected from the online bit like
meeting the fans if I did an actual meet
in Murray or whatever that's not real
that would be better I would like that
week I got can't silvers the way kind
already had an event schedule so I was
like I'm gonna go everybody was telling
about I want we should die
hello everyone love Lea and I was like
I'm losing loads of subs but everybody
here really likes me when it was coming
up to this election I tweeted about
Korbin
I'd look at the wrote the replies anyone
digging me out how to go through their
tweets I had I was searching like their
name and then
[__] so in other words and I was just
looking to dig them out like that
it's a weird nature that we have to
social media so it seems the game
associated major we have what are we
admit sure we hope to really people s
there's all the six have we all
experienced that very same thing yeah do
you ever imagine what your viewers
looked like yet would
they look like fifteen-year-old no lads
yeah that just I don't know though if
when I'm walking down the street and my
girlfriend says this girl from the right
she she can spot my viewers a mile off
especially in Manchester or book it was
16 or 17 that are wearing some sort of
you know sportswear you know clothing
jacket yeah they just go the walk
passing you just take a school about a
second there the one sitting down on the
floor with a coupe out there a second I
gave up on two pounds once walk you pop
cause it seemed really nice a them
yeah I've loved the older ones that know
me go you're from Chu Julie oh yeah yes
I get a lot of people come in bars yeah
you really what I think majority of my
audience must be about twenty years yet
everybody always says you and I make you
my one is probably a bigger in person
sometimes the intonation is a bit
they're gonna [__] me you're bigger and
aggressive and then they go what you
doing yeah well you did a Manchester do
you get is there anything that when you
go back and see your friends want to
school and stuff at they say to because
my one is always my school friends go or
what's it like no will any their that's
all I am to you I am just write your
self at what do you get just oh you're
far away you Jack what the people say if
people recognize you when you're out cuz
you've got a probably a little bit in
all their audience as well yeah I always
get recognized in clubs what what before
is it so Ella yeah
yeah always always the calendar you know
the what was a good video regardless of
what I said at the time but that makes
me then go and do a number four videos
on here all taxi driver it'll be the
Newcastle runs for me oh really
I lived a twenty-year-old that'll be
like what was so one of the podcast
guess it was like what was this one like
what was that one like I do - - was it
my old college cheaper generally used to
listen to happy hour and he cuz my
brother wants listen close me when all
your brothers on that and I went oh not
anymore go people cause any guy when you
get him in half a hour again no one o
hopefully when you let the schedule fit
just to be real just to be real I
thought it was a mistake that when used
to parted ways
yeah I thought it was from up from a
personal point of view I thought that
that was good that what you had was good
and I thought like it's broken though
you can still felt like the fourth chair
that's fancy
yeah I thought that the dynamic was good
as what I'm trying to say Jen and I mean
it wasn't every so much behind that I'll
be impossible to ever go into pro flakes
and just cause too many more problems as
well but it was tight that was a nice
thing smart it was actually because you
never turn the AC on
you did the podcast you the podcast the
AC in that studio is it this strange my
sexual tension between you two I'll give
it that wow so hot in there - it is
[__] hard work I just get ready now
it's by a lot of like 40-year old kind
of like Indian blokes in terms of ratios
of people yeah people of Asian descent
have have noticed me more than oh really
yeah mine was because I did that video
on Facebook years ago that was I say
that but I thought the pro-immigration
one
my friends went you got a guy to that
Islam video that's why they won't oh I
don't know you know I was best mates to
Tony Robinson really me and Thomas good
for your brand to stand up for labor and
no sort of thing but that's genuinely
what I believe like saying I'm saying
with you but I'll say whatever is good
so we were like Shia show politics I saw
you do a lot mmm I saw you but the
Corbin thing but that was that was a
shame that he backed out and then saying
within four minutes before use do on
that's a sat in the studio that's the
shame that's a big shame yeah
if I was in your position you made a lot
of Facebook posts about I said yeah
private ones some of that you look up to
and then and then if they don't say they
fit it's like yeah was a reporter when
he lost cord that's what you [__]
know because Judy said that he was gonna
vote conservative just on that and I was
like why would you just because of one
thing that I didn't completely disagreed
with that as I I'm not I'm not actually
a big Corbin fan I agree if he in about
anyone yeah go for the party not the
person Laura tonight I mean to
completely change your kind of political
views based on one interaction yeah yeah
and he cancelled because he went on the
Andrew [__] force many mysteries
happen to us like straight after and his
like aids it was like cool he's at a car
run up to that must be with your head it
says of where you stand
I'd be fed up if he if he canceled yeah
but I'd be like I said bake it busiest
week of his life yeah then if you didn't
say anything I'll be a bit like yeah
that's [__] rude yes I understand we
because I think the interview happened
like three hours before I don't know and
they because obviously everybody in our
cover it's Hari
yeah so what we people
big motor distantly thank you Alex all
the signs are still up same folk labor
and always everything time I passed my
when we should take Thank You Terence
academics the ball for well we'll just
have a chat about online about the air
conservatives nothing to get me on a
compilation about bullying Alex thank
you this year last year sure so Tony I
didn't realize that that was problem it
wasn't it did you sensitive mate I was a
compilation went upwards I'm Alex being
bullied for free minutes straight please
you've told me that because we'll get on
that my place and rightly so because I
was I was getting cocky well no I just
make it too many I said I saw it
am I am i recommended and I thought oh
it's just it was funny it's a joke
there's like this whole compilation of
me on the podcast or I was hammered and
then Lorenson Stephen mainly well that's
one off the podcast and Jack were there
so I make jokes about me and then it
became I ate slightly Scott Lee Scott
with half a million views Alex
mentioning not being on Stephen today of
course will notice TV Stephen damaged
even today was fine with me an apology
rightly so I don't remember happened I
just and I you actually read my reply
and I just went I went come on my
podcast and know how to have that
anymore
yes Eun was that happy hour now is he
cast it oh did he dump me as well
I have no idea what happens I know all
the recessive end is only about 25%
let's be real swinging you babe the
kiddos on the Comcast
well James James right it gives me a
periscope wash wafts of a tory am i
right no no hi is he I haven't seen this
guy's videos no disrespect obviously I'm
will take that person I've just watched
jour organism it's no disrespect it's
lovely when I met in there can I put
them yeah why did that one who uh so
it's one of those things where it with
me and James Italy she was just like it
wasn't that we necessary fell out over
anything it was like he wanted to do
very different things to me like put the
things in the dishwasher the right no it
was he wanted to he wanted to go he
decided by sea I would I was actually
just about you achieving the you ship
stuff every week which I know that works
and yeah it's pretty good very stick to
that but he very much didn't want to go
down the same route well I was going
down understandably he wants to do more
funnier videos and I'm not funny in
terms of what was his subjects
no just Joni forgive all the things are
courage I was good for James it was more
for him he wanted to do stuff it wasn't
as serious but you do still speak much
yeah we might we we've like there was a
better thing where we didn't talk for a
few months which I think it's necessary
after you end a project where you're
making of like a doing like every single
week even me and Jack it was good to
take that you need to take a couple
months off just to be like that's Burke
you I am I doing this because they see
like a weeding the dermis because we
need money we doing this to our views
that we doing this goes we're free
we're doing it because of any of that
stuff and there needs to be that thing
driving a lot of youtubers like go down
this thing where I pick James up when he
was super small so we always have to
reevaluate like he grew off you and then
and then was I why not go in the Sun II
know what I'm here and now no no because
I know I do feel it I was in Vegas no no
I would never say that back what I
picked him up I was like no I always the
thing is I I say mr. James I always knew
he always knew he was gonna be bigger
than my anybody else he was generally
he's so funny
and gets you more than most people like
when you find people 1k subs normally
there's a lot that you could go they
quickly don't really have a clue what
their him but and I was like I said to
my when you make me feel bad about what
I'm doing cuz I look at your videos and
I think you're so much better than me
how am I here and how are you there dan
I should do kept the laptop true you
wanna do it we'll do some emails welcome
wow wow I just say I think it's been
[__] ages since I had a woman on the
podcast isn't it yeah I mean we who was
the last woman on the podcast it was was
it the Polestar yeah yeah yeah no okay
there's one that says girl in need here
do you want me to go walk that walk yeah
what did you say well here you have the
book the the Vice basically because
you're a girl
we need a woman's advice no I don't
think it'll be bad I'm sure we'll
liberal cups will probably give exactly
the same advice
this one's called girl in need and it's
basically tailored around Brian so my
name is Heidi Heidi I'm 23 and I'm a
plus-size Welsh girl oh good good good
tits but fat chunky ass I know I found
you guys through my boyfriend watching
YouTube at first also not a fan of the
big hairy one but I I believe they mean
you but the more I watch you two big
scary one I now think you're pretty
sound all about mental health oh geez
she's got a boyfriend and she's emailed
for email and Brian soon I've got good
tits and a perfect chunky ass but she's
got a boyfriend you don't know the
message means sense Brian either but
it's absolutely fine myself excuse you
anyway so I would label myself as a bit
of a tomboy in the past I've suffered
with depression and fellows label us
she's has depression June Stephens
jumping with chair this is a [__]
truth I'm a lot better two years ahead
and I think I'm doing okay thumbs up she
actually does what she types with thumbs
up no I know my own business picking
[__] up all day I'm a dog walker so you
can find me on my own in the middle of
the woods right I think she's actually
giving you a look for a cereal kit Brian
my mother Tootsie
Wow for this we said no cheap jokes
Stephen just dived in it's amazing it's
good job on what the Musallam creepy I
know but it's just perfect if you ever
want to hide a body I know some good
spots well Brian I need a baby already
knows Logan anyway I feel that girls and
I said here we go this is the problem
really feel that girls and guys judge me
for my size before they get to know me
I'm a size 24 like
like she is mental 20 the fact that
she's a dog walker and she's a size 24
is quite impressive
she says 24 and I look like the fat
jolly one in the group but I love sex
like any dominance or hardcore I want it
I feel like I can ride a [__] better
than most girls as I have the fat ass
not that I'm digging myself up when I
begin
oh it says email light and yeah when i
hook up with guys I they always say
after how I shock how shocked they were
and it was good and they're wanting to
hook up again anyway whatever don't
judge me don't judge this book by its
cover gotta love this plus-size girls
basically she's saying she feels like
people judge her for a plus-size before
they get to know her the book don't want
to say the book there's no pictures
there is no book run and I can give you
the email yeah what you do with a girl
let me read she's confident does that
attract you also says by the way
favorite sex position is defo doggy and
reverse cowgirl I knew those reverse
cowgirl are just no girl reverse cowgirl
yeah I did say I would first that's
where you just go go Orozco because
always the dick goes it's a lot of
quantities or bends yes not comfortably
no I know in it I want it pointing me
towards me I prefer not to speak stop by
the way means glad she came home for
this segment of the [__] are you doing
what will say favorite sexual position
how many guys I genuinely
there must be there must be two like are
a few that you're like this is gonna
kneel and boom here welcome what's the
money shot okay where did you first kiss
will when where and why it was outside
there I don't know what it's called it's
like a brownish bar in Shoreditch and
it's like a bitter briefed on no it
wasn't no you know your first it I mean
I'm totally [__] oh really
of course it that's always do you know
Tommy what was your first day well to be
fair he had a massive advantage by one
point and he goes no changes Twitter
name for a week after love I detail I
love warrants around pictures yeah I
used to oh yeah you seem like a really
good cop that's my best mate yeah for
sure yeah I read you that really good
together as well have you so I know
she's punching but I'll just can I give
you some advice for ya while you're
together set up your own YouTube channel
some of the Instagram we were thinking
only fun absolutely that's good mail
this guy - no not literally killed your
audience in case you happens to me
honestly
she wrote the [__] blueprint on this
what's the best thing about being with
will apart from the clown what's the
best thing about being with the club
I've not got the clouds Club what's the
best thing about being with him I was
what's the thing that because God you
know I found me interesting about XO is
how will sobs got a public persona but
privately is actually a bit like Brian
he's actually nicer off-camera
which it does it for the Camarillo
Jesuit boys me I'm not being funny but
when he kisses you is his tongue action
good how did you kiss a girl by the way
I just can we can we have someone
describe that's what my current
girlfriend is let me do current lovely
oh yeah
suddenly does the video if will regulate
when he beats you oh geez oh wow I like
so so do you sorry
yes we Tyler Stevie told me to be funny
yesterday though you said that you only
found out he was doing the Bella video
outside the belt of him after it being
uploaded and she's I you might want to
run this by her future were you slightly
like we're gonna have to have a word
with this guy giving that much money to
another girl yeah if I know anything
about women I know that when they say
it's fine it's not fine Camila do you
think you understand like the game
better because you're with will you
literally could be a you Joe because
you're bad are on to us great and also
when we were doing the cuts not this is
already the video already PL mate
questions she knew more answers about
social media like youtubers or like post
a video and I'll mess it I'll send the
video to world I'll be like this is
things off her I don't mean like ideas
it's video idea well yeah yeah do you do
that just bounce things off your
girlfriend what about you Steven
my girlfriend she counts can you feel
that Alex just other wow we got any more
questions I've got loads of questions so
Mia I meant yeah
the Rosslyn Willard okay this is good
I'm just interested because I don't
think a lot of people out there don't
know I always thought this with EXO they
never knew how sweet the other three
were Oh
sugar syrup I know but what I mean is
like no one knows how nice will is off
camera no one knows how sweet you are
off camera yeah but no one actually know
it's just but for instance nobody knows
so for instance Brian's quite a [__]
yeah why I come yeah
but off camera he's very emotionally
bring him into the house you know yeah
yes great the offer of alcohol people
know that me a wooden hunger out Brian
if he was volatile to us in person be
surprised what money can do money and a
few beatings yes very good suit the
beyond the Alex YouTube yeah okay this
one's entitled is it okay to date my
best mate sister hey Brian and Laurence
and Mia and Steven and the guys yeah I'm
currently in close contact with my best
friend's sister for the past three
months and I feel as if I'm developing
feelings for her and she's the same
problem being my friend doesn't know I'm
scared that he either won't be okay with
it or there's a backlash
how's y'all ready done so with her no
and I might get might get from others
who think it is dog is the dog like a
life is life is very minimal
I really he says I really like this girl
and I don't want to stop a good thing
with her but I also want to be a good
friend I mean I guess this is a
difficult time how important the
friendship is cuz it could it could
impact that so what you're saying is if
you if you really feel like this
person's sure and it's like wow this
girl's amazing I want to make her the
person in my life great but if you think
there's a short-term thing no no I don't
think to do it to [__] over your friend
is funny and what people don't know son
is how nice well is I've know I've known
a lot of people have broken up their
girlfriends men dated their sisters of
their ex-girlfriend speaking of Ryan
what was that experience like wait so I
mean don't go out with their friends no
no no that is that is so untrue there at
the amount of time I mean I think in
London it's um um uncommon but if you go
to the rural areas there are definitely
so I'm an only child but Brian was it
like to date two sisters I did a mid
sister before how was that okay so
different absolutely fantastic Brian you
have a word with your mitten go look if
you don't want to do this I'm not going
to do this and give them the power
usually a probably thing well I rather
ibly with the block I know and I can
keep an eye on in trust and I actually
know the devil of who he is and then
some random off the street who could be
anything personal I would rather pick a
random or fight than you can stone for
sure
for example he's not your sister
no no if a good reason
yeah for good reason what does your
sister look like you the problem yeah
she's got a square jaw like it's a
fashion thing yeah that way you're where
you well you might just would fancy my
sisters but they will look like you it
was very hot why I've had three twin
sisters free and everybody one your
sisters are fit yeah free triplets if I
still might oh you know where does the
line get drama I mean where do you draw
the line
yeah where's your buddies smudge where
were you where you go I was born and
they beat Joe still a one-nil so did I a
mistake imagine if they had you been the
team they'd be 4-nil up I should go for
it if he gives the go-ahead hi Bonnie
Norwich yeah can always get more friends
what I've dated multiple males just
those before at the same time like a
couple of me mates updated their sisters
but with with respect though it's been
like oh do if you're like alright with
it Brian you ever think that people tell
you it's fine because of the way you are
no massage you did you never feel bad
about it not because like they knew
about it was cool and I tried that also
there's a certain way of treating your
maid sister in there like you're not
gonna just be like whatever when I was
15 I was 6 foot 2 and 15 story so I was
a big boy like I remember the teachers
realize like looking up at me going [__]
this and it went down yeah yeah
so a while yes do you think women are
attracted to you more because of your
size I think everyone has a type order
so like you have this data type your
last likes you some girls like big men
some girls like say some girls want a
six-pack some girls want a guy like me
yeah you have a six-pack the girl over
friends some girls love a nasal voice
and that's what does one this yeah she's
she's never gonna wet yet but that times
covered that sounds coming in as I say
how did you you met her in a club yeah
a men dated her and obviously proposed
her in the end
yep where's this go I'm just wondering
about it was good at I never seen the
video of your proposal because I have a
like oh my god I've called the fridge
and I was debating like released I
really want to see did you provoke
really got me really Creighton what
really got me was the moment you
surprised that with the holiday I was
like I'm [__] sure she thought you
were going to [__] Bulgaria I know my
[__] cried yeah don't post that well
send me names you can be my next upload
so I am my whole life is advent
calendars make no I'm assuming was it
London comes oh he came out can you
imagine if I booked there for the last
day now I made this massive advent
calendar and every day I bought her a
present yeah and the advent calendar had
a poem in it which led to the location
of the present right but this is where
it gets good
right so she it had like a you imagine
like a like a like a one-word crossword
thing like eight letters or whatever it
was so it would say like blah blah blah
blah blah blah and the answer would be
considered free the answer would be like
a fridge and right you know the
chocolate in there or something Oh
should write fridge in next day next
thing next day and then on the last day
the poem would lead to read the first
letter of every door and then all the
locations it was like F for fridge I
Yona will you marry me very good I just
get the feeling all these in the in the
24 readout as Fiona will you will you
marry me how you didn't make that a
video I'm so good for you what yeah he's
brought this others oh that's a shame Oh
genuinely when people like Fiona South
will you marry me 24 so day 25 was a
question mark and there was there was
there was three blocks but she could put
why yes I said but I think that's the
best proposal I've ever heard of I'm
gonna take a little time so what did he
do on Christmas Day yeah and because the
like the present on the last day was the
ring if she'd have said no and vinay
genuinely though have you saved yourself
better cut along the way the Christmas
people people think about him the fact
that you went through all of that shows
like your persona is just like that
compare what you really are it's the
complete opposite I never saw such a
lector was what he didn't tell says he
proposed in McDonald's and it was a
really like deep saying yeah this is
amazing
[Laughter]
[Music]
I can't I mean I really
you should approach a doe legends to get
a girl to marry as many more yeah I've
got another one this one's called must
lose virginity
it seems pretty urgent I felt this
person wrote it
just before sex it's max it's I can't
say hey TJ and Laurence and the guys you
can call me anything you want
is anyone gonna name virgin good I hate
to be another one of those shy nervous
guys looking for girl advice but I could
really use some help basically I'm a
virgin and there's a girl who I think I
might like I'm in college we have a
common class however we don't really
have the chance to talk my question is
do you think I should just grow a pair
of balls and talk to her when I can or
message her on insta which I got from a
friend also I think I should go all-in
well do you think I should go all-in and
ask her out straight away
or think you think I should talk to her
and get hurt or Emilia Lenape dies
approaching you to be fairly well here
both perspectives but there's one woman
at the table her Instagram he got it off
of a friend yeah he never had her actual
Instagram yes it's a red flag but that's
a rich and I can relate to this a big
time I think he's under estimating his
potential okay in terms of what you
could be I was there in college I I
butchered any chance on for the female
because I was just like no way we should
be interested I would be in their
position I think just speaks them try to
have some confidence in yourself develop
that and then when you get to 23 have
sex with them so I would go different
route I say I should make a Christmas
calendar yes every single day you spell
will you have sex with diabetes
seriously as a guy approaching a girl
Mia is it creepy when someone out of the
blue
before you were obviously with stud like
this would message you and be like hey
babe I'm sort of thinking you might if
she's seen him in class this sort of
like over there they exchanged a few
look he said that she even follow him on
Instagram for me that's a bit strange
because I'm like you ever like we go on
Instagram you can sort your request by
talk how do you think I dream that one
day and it's just a bunch like you
showed me that video that tick-tock girl
I made about [__] you can you [__] me
someone for those who don't know used
your picture and a girl to dance and
mouthed the words to a song can you [__]
me emo boy in your picture would appear
no I'm not up to do with all this you
know remember you know I think I even
from the opposite side we get a message
it's not that straightforward it's like
question just y1 diems more sort of wall
DM that you've ever heard like out of
the blue like first a.m. first one to
destroy a back passage and as I felt was
that the first tweet you'd ever heard
offer pretty much the fact will you
destroy Alec my back passage bit bit of
blue yeah exactly
and as a
a beta male I went actually I'm curious
why certainly you must not horrible
messages I'm going through my messages
now he's dead G exper this so yeah
revenge is sweet brother he's got a
thing for Chris
it just says [__] I would eat you [__]
hole up she's done you damn ironic
because my most outrageous message I
ever heard out the blue was of a woman's
[__] really just ten points at the
back set up jokes absolutely incredible
parable big awesome right how close in
on the [__] was it I mean it wasn't
like right up it was just like like
completely out of the blue was about 1
a.m. on a Saturday night sort of thing
you know I mean [__] it
shoot your shot yeah ironically she's
clearly this another podcast cuz she
definitely picked the right area yeah
yeah she was yeah she's all he likes an
[__] yeah sits next one long enough
yeah mutual Chuck what and he use had
any like random ass what was so what
happened with that how'd you feel on
James James trolls for those wondering
Jesse and the second covered and Jacob
Texas very complimentary and most people
no message to be going that all thanks
for not bullying me but he won't very
much the opposite way yes why does he
the wording Sophie's why I I wore these
[__] Joker's in the video and I now
you realize this intro song the one
where you're making the tea in the
kitchen yes you're really good videos so
may I decided you so they're doing a
normal video I guess the joke is
obviously a sister so I made a cup of
tea as I made the video for me I bought
them and it was attractive way you have
got a big penis no way no way it's
probably relative I won again Charles is
attention to going on the podcast I just
needed title at the James Charlesworth
my his fault because if you read the
[__] comments on this video even to
this day it's just all about the
inference be honest have sexual we're
all roasting me what you've been doing
much the dirtiest thing you've ever done
go back to the portal ooh sleep sleep
with my significant other a threesome
when you're bisexual I always imagined
that maybe you'd have them sort of
someone chugging your ass and the new
shaggers tomorrow
you'd hope that's what you get but it's
knowledge payments at some point yes you
watch porn you know I wish I could go
that way but very much isn't the same
yeah I don't get shakes for 23 years
don't you get a compilation on housing
school were you Steven are you enjoying
being a sexually active adult Brian but
I can deal with it instead of going
through the whole playlist we've
shortened that right now just go through
the whole because for those who might
have forgotten you you made it through a
long DJ set time now it's just you know
the best of now 49 the condoms are off
exactly are you still condom using or
not using well right I'll get into this
now because my girlfriend's come off the
pill because it makes her a little bit
on edge okay come on I hate it when
women say that it's such a Bali but but
she picked a specific type of condoms to
buy and in there in this pack you get
you get cocktail flavors condoms yeah
I'm going
we have another child and if we good for
the animals yeah and I hope everyone has
a happy Christmas at this point on
Christmas did not happens am i right and
yeah I just love you guys if you think
2019 was a bad year for me you probably
don't realize just how bad it was it was
weird it was crazy it was painful it was
one of the hardest years of my life and
I feel like I need to tell you what it
was like just to close the [__] door
and it all this might be my most honest
video it probably is my most honest
video I've ever made I don't know if he
YouTube has ever done this before I'm
taking a leap with this one and I hope
you go with me
you
[Music]